well well well we are back yep
missed you guys on Monday
I really really hate missing shows man
really do uh today's episode is
sponsored by Honey stamps.com and
hellofresh thank you we love we love our
sponsors
you know I woke up on uh
Monday morning it's it was really a
weird illness
Sunday I was up with the kids
the kids are up all night you know sleep
is an issue obviously but I was up with
Bruce at like 4 00 a.m when he finally
fell asleep
and I went to bed obviously pretty late
but when I woke up around 11
I felt so bad dude it was weird just
came out of nowhere man
like in the in the middle of a really
deep flu-like symptom thing
yeah I see you guys were super sad you
guys were in deep morning
over uh what we were worried about
Monday episode
[Music]
yeah I know I know what you guys are up
to none of these beers are cracked nice
try well we were just getting in the
party kicking off nice try losers yeah I
didn't drink [ __ ] no we were just you
guys were working all day oh Sam's the
one really partying
who's Sam
uh right she's just penis bottle now
by the way there was a really funny
picture of Sam on Friday who someone was
covering her head oh yeah yeah who's
that who was that your Masterpiece baby
someone uh you were covering her head
well I don't I can't see what's
listening I'm not gonna point fingers
but I always respectfully remind Zach
that he's the tallest yes somehow he
always ends up in the middle
um but here's well that's not a problem
what does it matter yeah
in the middle you're most visible yeah
Sam would be more visible he Zach is
tall enough to be oh he could be behind
Ethan if Zach yeah but everyone was like
yo this is such a beautiful picture Sam
well it's very funny
um Zach what do we think about this it
seems that uh a b is saying why not
change places with Sam
that that's fine I have no issue with
that
there is Zach says no issues
probably
[Music]
psych I'm done
yep
can I see that again I missed it because
it was covered
here is Ethan Klein
psych I'm done
see off the resolution
it's a little okay okay okay just a
little um
little pick me up there yep
good I like that thank you guys nothing
more than that right
no even with like the full day off no
yeah okay good well it wasn't a day off
we were drinking right right I was
pretty [ __ ] we were busy together
yeah okay fair enough yeah by the way
side note
um Philly D Philly DeFranco is a pretty
boy
um he asked me to add that to the doc
and so it's he's a pretty boy why are
you talking to Philly dude he responded
to our tweet today he said to add that
to the docket
hey which tweet we tweeted out what
we're gonna be talking about today
today's tweet he's showing some live
hold on hold on hold on okay
this is sweet Philip DeFranco is a
pretty boy oh this one well I don't know
who's according to who Philly I mean uh
you're skinny Legend but I mean pretty
boy I mean who gave you that moniker
he's a pretty boy I think it's pretty
I'm not saying he's not pretty but whoa
whoa whoa I mean you can't be
editorializing our show I mean who is he
pretty cringy we're friends
all right
oh [ __ ] not that yeah so anyway okay
good excellent yeah so I was feeling
really sick and um
but today today I'm feeling much better
I got a good night's sleep last night
and uh this is sick
yeah
thank you
uh so moving on we got obviously a lot
to talk about as you guys see from the
title uh nelkboy
Steve will do it
went way too far obviously the Steve
will Yank It dog jerking meme is getting
to him severely
and he's not acting like a dude who did
not jerk off his dog he's acting like a
dude who very much did jerk off his dog
and he's mad at us
for noting what was obvious and he went
on the attack I'm the cool dad when I
saw what he said about Ila I audibly
gasped I tell you
yeah I was drinking something I spit it
out
I I'm not even kidding yeah it's time to
mount sound the words I I swear to God
oh I love the drummer boy the horn it's
all coming together
okay now can we get some bullet fire
Zach
like distant gunfire
not close but distant
maybe distant explosions not lasers not
lasers sure one hour distant gunfire
sound effect Luke
that's too loud but I had it full volume
hold on let me I'm talking like miles
away you know
I I promise you man I was sitting with
Theodore when I watched this clip and I
said oh no he didn't I said that out
loud and Theodore was like what what
happened Daddy what what did he say or
something I was like oh don't worry so
it's just uh work related
when dare show my son that foul demonic
language that dog jerk offer used
against my wife oh that's good
wow we're on the battlefield boys he's
giving me those numb flashbacks I'm
having to ride the uh the fader here
to keep it nice and you know low bed
wait why did it sound like Mario just
got a coin
what was that I I don't know that was in
this video or not did you play something
back man
and women we come together here
to declare war
on our adversary
Steve will Jerk It
this man has been jerking off his dog
relentlessly
when I jerk off Donnie for years
and has the audacity to attack
Ela
that what what now that was Mario
getting a coin okay
and I shall commit we shall fight on the
sea we shall fight on the land
we shall fight in the gym
we shall fight with masks on or off I
believe an individual citizen in this
country has a right to own we shall
acquire nuclear weapons
Steve will [ __ ] you know what you're
about to jerk your dog off for the last
time Steve
Steve you better get jerking you better
enjoy it while you can you [ __ ] you
know why Steve's so jacked from jerking
his dog off all the time
worked up a lot of muscle works for him
one's for the dog
Steve you degenerate [ __ ]
you disgusting freak
[Laughter]
oh you [ __ ] up now
Chris house says I'm an anime tattoo
artist Ethan and the crew always have
debates about terrible tattoos I think
talking to a tattoo artist could add
some perspective side note client of
mine and I bonded over our mutual of the
show thank you uh Chris house I'm sure
as an anime tattoo artist you've seen
your fair share of praying
tattoos eh yeah
ah I just started to get throat pain I'm
just warning you guys I didn't feel it
but now I feel it
Jay's music keep it going keep the worst
stuff going I like it as a mute
what the [ __ ] is that it's an A-10
Warthog uh doing a stray thing run
you say what
like a oh
wow probably unnecessary well I'm just
I'm trying to Pepper in you know a
variety of sounds but yeah Jay's musings
thank you for the gifted
true huh
glad you're on the men good sir hope the
family stays well
I'm super pissed at Steve the fupas have
your back one hundred thousand percent
thank you Jay
you guys are gonna gasp when you see
what this man said and I am not
overplaying it I'm gonna send it am I
overplaying it I lost my mind right no
not at all
he almost made it through the interview
he went on Bradley Martin's podcast
almost made it through
and then at the very end he had to say
the the lamest ship the dirt the
stupidest [ __ ] that completely
undermined everything he had said
previous might I add right a hundred
percent
Steve Steve
it's gonna be fun to watch that clip so
man the barricades or like you go cow
style I'm about to [ __ ]
hey Steve
where would we be without Steve the man
is jerking off his dog
man dog is man's best friend yet nobody
jerks him off
think about what the dog does for us
and nobody sucks jerks the dog off it's
outrageous bad dog
it's outrageous
think about it what the heck the dog
doesn't have thumbs he can't touch
himself
and here's Steve a good man bad dog
jerking off his dog and scooping the
come out his own words not mine
he's a good man
now how dare you attack him where would
we be
without Steve and his and now he's the
cool dad
that dog loves Steve I'll tell you what
man the barricade and he'll never forget
the time he's slipped a finger and
he did a little extra for the dog he
didn't have to do that but he did
where would we be without men like Steve
a nuclear warhead Warhead
mm-hmm
wow I hope you're shivering in your
boots there Stevo no he must be scared
yeah he should be you guys I swear to
God I'm not exaggerating we got a few
top of the show things and then we're
gonna get to Steve wiljerk it
Steve will yoinket
uh Joe check out this Tick Tock you guys
know I've been talking about getting
uh my haircut I was supposed to do it
yesterday obviously I was sick but um I
was gonna do Jeff's Barber Shop friends
of the show
and he actually messaged me before I had
the chance because I was sick I wasn't
going to make it
that his uh dog passed away
and he needed some time and I uh so my
heart goes out to Jeff there yeah I felt
bad he's had that dog for 12 years
you know
I told I told him I said man I'm you
know it's not fair that it's just not
fair that dogs die they should live
forever and I truly mean that it's just
not fair
you know why don't they live longer it's
just not enough time
it's just not
I'll get somebody working on that
there's got to be something we can do
about that I mean what are we doing
I'll reach out I'll see what I can do
yeah what do we do about it
yeah but you know
the thing about losing dog it's such a
personal experience because
mourning the loss of a dog for the
person whose dog passed
it is like losing a family member it's
it's as it's as impactful it's it's as
special of a relationship and
what's especially weird is that nobody
can really share that grief with you
because nobody has that relationship
with that dog like you do and a lot of
times it's like oh you lost a dog you
move on everyone sees it like you're not
mourning you move on and people don't
give you that same
uh
kind of that same consideration that
same grieving period
and especially if you're Steve I can
only imagine when that when Donnie
passes
it's at losing a dog
yeah I mean and in Jeff's case he lost
his dog and his best friend and in
Steve's case when his dog passes God
forbid he'll be losing a dog and his
lover I'm the cool dad now
so that's so I'm really not looking
forward to that for for uh
I don't even wish that on on uh Steve
yeah but anyway my heart goes out to
Jeff I'm
you know what I I know the pain and I
wish you all the best
uh Jeff ladies and gentlemen Friends of
the show
we send our condolences to a friend of
the show Jeff whitock and uh we we hold
him in our hearts and our prayers
and uh anything else here is but but we
got this tagged in this Tick Tock that
actually got a lot of likes it's kind of
cool that man has a furry [ __ ] neck
bro that was my first thought when I saw
this I never seen a neck that furry and
I know it's all shaved down and stuff
but it looks
like it goes down this far
great right no yeah yeah no it's kind of
shocking right but okay that's not
really the point of this video
did we check if this was copyrighted
uh this specific one I don't believe we
did
so let's just mute it then
you know I'm just noticing right now
I've actually spoken to this girl before
she's a fan of the show she was gonna do
my hair before the crater Clash oh that
would have been awesome why didn't you
do it I don't know anything I could pull
it off Lena told me I should do it but I
don't know well I definitely can't pull
it off which is why it's funny about it
but she does these incredible buzz cut
colored I don't know how would this even
work like does that last
I believe so yeah it's just like
bleaching what because a little but then
how come Ela
I mean die will fit so with each block
the color will slowly and slowly get
more muted but right yeah it'll stay
there for for a few washes at least
she's really talented I sent her
Instagram she uh made by Jackie Bieber
she actually does Dennis Rodman's hair
oh for real yeah
yeah so I wonder what I should get so my
plan is I'll do Jeff's Barber Shop and
then God love him I'm gonna buzz it all
off
and get my hair tie-dyed from this
genius
uh get you know what you guys give me
your ideas the best idea I'll have her
do and I was thinking like prolapse anus
I mean God's the you know I'll do it
anything man y'all just tell me what you
really do that I mean I am committed to
the pro I'm
explaining that to you're gonna have
like meetings
ow I don't know people for like Teddy
fresh or something and just have like a
prolapse I'll wear a beanie if I need to
okay I think if you did a quick scroll
through her Instagram you get some uh
inspiration some of these are wild she
had a McDonald's head for someone
McDonald's logo yeah well if you guys
have any
um ideas let me know but yeah I'm pretty
exciting super talented check it out
so that's fun something to look forward
to there thank you
uh love you've been complaining about
not enough memes on the subreddit
uh your mic is muted there love up you
know hold on and loves defense we did
ask for more memes last week so maybe
that contributed
yeah am I back hello yeah
um well they do they certainly delivered
uh they did your Call to Arms check this
out this one's really good H3 1800 Style
what do you think
I liked it I like it a lot my forehead
looks too big though isn't it
well back then maybe that's the standard
or that that's like a good big forehead
Vibes yeah Dan be looking like he got
some fetal alcohol
what I thought he looked like a genius I
don't know your eyes are like kind of
[ __ ] low set
or like deep set you look like you don't
drink water just whiskey those are Dan's
eyes though
okay what Dan say something
that was extremely rude it's not really
you
looks like me
Dan I think you look like a genius who
maybe did thank you a lot of cocaine I
did not think it was going there Jesus
it's not a real person Dan it's a
[ __ ] that is me okay all right sir
Dan Nathan Nathaniel that's word love
[Music]
um
hey but here hey hey you know what Ela
back in the 1800s be like cover up you
[ __ ]
I could see your neck
[Music]
be more modest
uh this is giving me Westworld Vibes
young Samantha Templeton
young Samantha Templeton
[Music]
what do we think
class
Grace
I hate it
I think it's glossy like that
oh
Mr Ian Slater
they did me what kind of degenerative
disease does he look like he has it
definitely looks like he got something
doesn't it I mean look at his [ __ ]
eye oh interesting like
ridden with syphilis he has a mess this
man has dying of dysentery
he
broke his ankle fording a river
yeah standards bit by a rattlesnake
looks like his eyes are dissolving I
mean what [ __ ] disease is that
yeah that's real
it looks like my the beard is like um
like a vegetable growing out of my face
like the root
reverse right yeah the Beards back then
were wild man it was all about making
them like a [ __ ] as possible
oh Mr Abdullah
[Music]
Mr Abdullah
yeah did they base it off of that photo
that he hates of himself I don't know I
like the same here's the fire bro the
swirlies I think it's sick yeah how'd
you do that
I don't know my great grandfather Mad
Dog
baby
[Music]
the fastest shot in the West
[Music]
oh Mrs Lena
cover up you [ __ ]
sorry
I could see you below your necklace I'm
gonna send that clip to Lena's family
with no contact
you more modesty please damn it
you're gonna make the men go crazy
is that this one's kind of nuts I didn't
even recognize you bro
but you look good actually thank you
mutton chop Z dude that beard is next
[ __ ] level yeah you should go for
that dude how'd they even think to do
their hair like that like that's just so
out of pocket it was the style at the
time Ulysses S Bernstein over there like
here's what you're gonna do you're gonna
grow a satchel off the side of your face
it looks like you could you know it's
the ultimate flavor saver
yeah you could put a tater tot and you
could even add a zipper right here there
you go dude put your cash in there your
gold your silver
young love
oh now that's uh the vibe yeah I like it
I like it yeah
oh she's
Olivia they did Olivia dirty it is so
hurtful something went wrong something
is so wrong
oh yeah
no no thank you no thanks at least she's
dressing modestly unlike those other
[ __ ] those harlots those damn harlots
yeah at least the fit is popping that
fit is fire the face is lacking
[Music]
you could cover up your hair next time
though
who the [ __ ] is this oh Cameron Jesus
who is Cam
it doesn't look like you at all cameras
up dude I look like an inventor
it looks like him yeah now that I see
like the eyes and stuff but yeah so here
it is Ye Olde H3 program there it is
ladies and gentlemen you're asking for a
Rebrand there it is nice
what idiots what losers to live back
then you God can you imagine being born
in that [ __ ] Century what [ __ ]
idiots what were you doing back then
weirdos you're walking around the
umbrellas like what are you what are you
doing idiot oh I got a cold pound
umbrella
Penguin brand I ride around in a steam
steam engine oh
it's weirdos
dumbass idiot [ __ ] morons I'm
surprised those idiots even got us here
uh so there's that fun little meme there
top of the show
one other top of the meme top of the
meaning top of the meme to you
now
maybe it's just the hater of me
because I seem to be alone in this
opinion and you guys know I'm a hater
ass [ __ ] self-labeled self-identifying
[Music]
why is 28 of Taco Bell trending
I'm giving it I'm gonna click it I saw
it earlier it's some dude said inflation
so bad that he got lunch at Taco Bell
and cost 28 and everyone's like how much
[ __ ] food did you hurt hold on wait I
gotta watch it hold the [ __ ] phone
bro you are a monster how much Taco Bell
did you get [ __ ] lunatic
what okay yeah I mean admittedly you
wonder how bad inflation is yesterday
yes I had a nice lunch at Taco Bell cost
me about 28 at Taco Bell for lunch no
people need to pay for those things and
no shot let's how many how much is 28 I
mean I could eat 28 of Taco Bell mainly
I go to Taco Bell but
sorry no no go ahead we went last night
32 bucks for both of you yeah
it's expensive but not as expensive no
20 bucks for two for two people I feel
like that's good 28 for one did you get
like 90 things yeah like let me know
your order first I I ordered 20 for 28
bucks very often but when you're ready
weren't you ordering for days you said
you were like you was buying like 40 of
Taco Bell a night yeah but it's like
three nights in a row yeah but you were
putting it in the freezer you said one
time I did that that I eat a lot I'm not
a big man but I eat a bunch he's a
secret guy bro you don't eat that much I
was sitting next to your house when we
were ordering
I could eat more than you I'm sure oh
[ __ ] he definitely eats a lot oh stop it
don't even step to me [ __ ]
that's interesting though I don't know
dude I was I know got that young man's
stomach you know how that was yeah
listen
I remember us eating together
we would order food and I would eat
circles around you I would even know
like oh he used to think he doesn't eat
that much that's good for him I ordered
the five Patty burger from Five Guys or
the other place the the in and out yet
Place yeah five by five yeah those
patties are small
[ __ ] though it's like a little bit of a
fika wait they don't make five by fives
anymore I don't know called out
I love you but they don't make that do
they cap out at four yeah four by four
yeah
it was a four by four yeah oh yeah did
you eat a ten by ten too love yeah I I
am at 40. okay but wait wait wait he did
eat a ten by ten so wait but you guys
are saying that 28 dollars a Taco Bell
isn't
is legit I just I don't know when you
order home though when you order home
an average lunch is not good oh when you
order a home when you order from
Postmates of course delivery fees yeah
you can't include that that's like
that's like 20 on top every time he
didn't say that he said I went to Taco
Bell no he said no he said when I
ordered a home
oh in the video he said he ordered a
home no love said that oh oh God
okay I think it's crazy
and listen I love Taco Bell in fact last
night because I didn't eat for two days
I was tasting time I was just it entered
my mind I was like talk a hard taco
supreme
with sour cream and tomato I know that
feeling so well
I'm feeling it should we get Taco Bell
[ __ ] yeah we should
Leah can maybe grab it on the way back
Sam how you feel about Taco Bell
I feel really good about it yeah I feel
really good about it ordering Taco Bell
right now with us Yo Taco Bell sponsor
me bro they keep [ __ ] with us they
keep sending us gift cards and all this
[ __ ] just pay me we could do this
every day it could be fun talk about
things
favorite but isn't it like one dollar
for a taco and this [ __ ] spent
28 bucks
probably got chalupas those do add up
quick
yeah some items yeah it just really
depends on what you get I guess there's
some stuff on there that's kind of
expensive but really you can still eat
there for super [ __ ] cheap dude
chalupa crunch is like a five dollar
Taco that is one thing that I dude
they're little Chipotle really recommend
potato soft tacos they're like a buck 50
or something that should that's good let
me let me see it yeah I mean a taco a
crunchy okay so the prices have gone up
a bit oh wow yeah crunchy taco supreme
is 230. those used to be 99 Cents man
when I was a kid yeah
or like about 40 years ago yeah yeah no
no not that long ago a chalupa uh Taco
is 389.
let's look at the combos because that's
what most people get right I mean
what you get three things a drink for
8.50 what are you talking about how'd
this man spend 28 dollars
that's insanely cheap that is pretty
cheap especially we're getting 1500
calories in your body wait they like the
calorie to dollar ratio is pretty good
there wait this prices can't be right
three crunchy tacos just combo for 660.
that is I mean you're on tacobell.com I
think the prices are right
clap what the [ __ ] you can't get a combo
for five bucks
[Music]
burrito Taco nachos and a drink for five
dollars that doesn't make any sense
I can't be that no I think it is I'm
with you all right no it can't those
prices don't make sense dude well maybe
they charge more in LA or something five
dollars we're on a premium Market
premium Taco Market here talking about
the LA beef tax you think there would be
Taco deflation in LA with the amount of
like taco trucks and
here let me let me put in our ZIP code
here what's our ZIP code or just how
about we don't say that on there well
we're in L.A
just put our address 90210 yeah exactly
thank you somebody just donated 50 and
said here have some Taco Bell on me
shout out Josh riddle 50 bucks we could
get like four tacos according to this
guy that's barely one for me
thank you brother Legend I can't control
my goose
what a guy that ninja is man
excuse me oh we haven't talked about
that yet
I don't know this prices are kind of
disgusty bro we'll Circle
you're on tacobell.com but how do you
find they're lying how breed tortilla oh
come on lettuce bring it all totally
differently hire someone to make it and
then hand it to your ass for five
[ __ ] dollars that's a totally
different a deal that's a different
conversation all together okay it's not
five bucks
something's off here anyway let's move
on we're gonna get Taco Bell though
uh uh moving on um we were oh yeah we're
gonna talk about something really
important
[Music]
are beautiful sponsors because we're at
the 30 minutes no our Taco Bell order
okay so Lena can get on the way back I
could ask her if she did she go to your
house actually you know what
it'd be interesting to hear what your
guys's Taco Bell order is
I don't know if that's that interesting
I'm interested I kind of want to know
pretty vanilla my my Taco Bell it's it's
like
I feel like my order is a time it's a
place in time because when everybody was
going vegan on YouTube I was also vegan
at the time so everyone was like okay
here's what you got to do you got to get
a Crunchwrap you have to replace the
beef with beans no sour cream no cheese
make it Fresca add potato and that's
what I've done you still do that it's so
good that is this solid order right
there so how do you so tell Amy that
let's see the LA Taco all right vegan
tell the Selena say sour cream uh to
replace beef with beans no sour cream no
cheese making Fresca all that all that
all that can you just text me just text
me
yeah for myself I think I just want like
I'm loving those Taco Supremes anyone
with me oh yeah that Dorito Taco
Supremes
I can't follow you down this path for me
I followed you for years Ethan I cannot
follow you down what's wrong with the
talk stream what do you like got beef in
it
I know you're a vegetarian bro that's
all I'm saying I can't follow you you
said who's with me I said I cannot
follow you down this path
I love I love their like
re-hydrated beef surprise it's so hard
they brought back the Mexican pizza
which I think was like genius marketing
to get rid of it for whatever reason
that's what they always do yeah is that
good I'm not sure he has no I love it
experience really
it's always sold out you sell out since
it's been back it's been sold out I I
don't get it probably once out of
everything
it's funny this people are so uh
passionate about Taco Bell
I see lots of comments of passionate
taco bellians Mexican pizza for Life
cheesy Fiesta potatoes bro I gotta say
those potatoes are insane they're so
good those cheesy Fiesta
that's part of my order I'd be having a
I'd be having a fiesta in my toilet
though
hell yeah brother
beefy melt
all right let's uh let's let's take this
off there they're gonna have to pay us
if they want us to have this in-depth
conversations about Taco Bell because I
guarantee everyone knows what they're
getting for lunch now
you hear that Taco Bell
all right let's thank our sponsors and
then we'll get to the Rock wanting to
eat this baby
rock is about the video of the year
coming up
already I didn't think anyone would be
able to surpass uh weights and fish but
just a few short days later
the guy's looking at him that's a meal
to the Rock boy
ah yummy that's some good protein and
the stem cells forget about it
regenerative quantities in a top and a
young child
real quick what are you what's your
order
we're sending the orders right now and I
need yours
you know I like the beanie cheese
burrito that hits super [ __ ] hard
just like a classic bean and cheeser
so let me let me do this yep
[Music]
let me do this yep three Taco Supremes
free Taco Supremes yes yes got it and
two bean cheese and rice burritos two
that's a lot of eating cheese and rice
oh I like well let me calculate what is
the calories
it's probably only you know
2300. wait okay so hold on a a taco
supreme has 190 calories okay and you're
getting three so that's let's call it
600. yeah that's fine 1.3 million no Cav
Kev I know yeah
bean cheese and rice and then top and
then um bean and cheese burrito Taco
Bell let's just say just to give you an
idea bean and cheese Taco Bell burrito
is oof 400. oh
that's that's that cheese
so if I were to eat what I ordered which
is three tacos and two burritos that is
not good
that's gonna be putting me at like uh
1500 calories already
look I'm not trying to bust balls here
but you've been doing so well on your
diet
it's Taco Bell is always going to be
there man you know are you saying don't
go that hard yeah yeah I think I'm going
too hard how about yourself that guy
coming Supreme I come in there's plenty
of food like I'm not in the way I am I
am I'm gonna be a buzz kill and I am
protesting Taco Bell because you're like
I'm not getting [ __ ] up baby I'm not
getting it hold on hold on hold on hold
on we're definitely getting Taco Bell
thank you this is why I'm asking about
the college because thank you Zach I'm
down 20 pounds by the way you look
[ __ ] 20 pounds yes don't stop I'm not
that's why I'm asking about the calories
but look you gotta look at this one's
always gonna be there do you wanna you
know it's just like the color the diet
I'm doing Zach I eat what I want and I
just I plan okay fair enough playing
around the calories that I'm eating you
know what I mean fair enough and you
know to each his own but look I'm just
saying you're looking really good
no willpower thank you bro thank you so
let's revise that then let's say
yeah so those tacos hit hard and they're
not as they're really light which I like
you know so let's say 600
plus maybe I should just skip the
burrito altogether that thing is [ __ ]
gnarly eh
right or I could do three talk or I
could do two tacos and a burrito
which would be 800 calories
which is somewhat reasonable
right
in it yeah something like that something
yeah
all right let's do that two Taco
Supremes and one
bean cheese rice burrito
thank you
and that's on guards
got it oh my gosh locked in thank you
all right exciting times yes I'm down 20
pounds I weighed this morning
fantastic
you know who would have thought that not
eating food for two days would be good
for my diet that's basically what
happened
did I tell you to talk about so
nostalgic though nothing hit like that
[ __ ] boy yeah right it's the best I've
been getting done with Taco Bell since I
was a [ __ ] kid it was probably the
one of the worst first things I spent my
own money on
some [ __ ] tacos I was introduced to
Taco Bell by a friend when I I didn't
start eating until it was like 18. like
I didn't I know really yeah
so what did you eat first when you went
there uh Crunchwrap Supreme
um chalupa
um but to this day the Crunchwrap
Supreme is my favorite that's so
interesting yeah yeah man uh Samantha
think of the gifted hi David just wanted
to say hi hi David just want to say hi
to my boyfriend since we normally watch
the spot together it's a message to
David right via caught me off guard
there oh by the way just a little thing
we did upload our members only podcast
yesterday for our members only who we
love so well
I was sick so it was a little it was a
little uh touch and go but
um it's there we talked about our
favorite shows everything we've been
watching me and Ila together so that's
up for our members who we love thank you
thank you all right let's thank our
sponsors and get to the Brock who he
doesn't need Taco Bell bro people just
hand him beards babies to eat can you
post mates a baby because I think that's
what happened here
I would love to Postmates just just
imagine he post made it a baby and this
is I was delivered oh yeah baby
this he goes this is going to taste good
thank you guys I'm gonna eat this right
now
what are you spoiling the video man
I got a lot to break down about that
yeah
all right thank you to honey yes sir
it's honey
it's easy way to save when you're
shopping on your iPhone or Computer Love
honey whenever I shop online in ela we
but you know it doesn't really matter
where you are if it's makeup Furniture
food computers Amazon honey is there to
help you save
um thanks to Honey Manuel searching for
coupon codes this thing in the past
honey is the free shipping tool that
describes the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one of fines to
your cart here's how it works imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites and when you check out the honey
button appears and all you have to do is
Click apply coupon wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you will watch the price
drop magically
pull something up Dan I mean the savings
are insane
120 oh yeah 21 bucks
off 122 purchase
off a 143. holy smokes dude was this uh
an ELO one
uh I think this one was actually from a
fan oh okay great even better yep
uh it's insane you're literally just
it's a browser you install on two clicks
it doesn't cost anything it's free to
download
boom boom it's installed and then when
you're shopping across the internet or
on your iPhone uh at checkout it just
automatically notifies you like hey we
got a coupon it's going to save you 20
bucks or I mean it's it's fantastic it's
free money dude
uh it really is
I I would venture to say it saved us a
thousand dollars by now honestly how
much money saved you guys come on
uh
hundreds of thousands
it saved me a lot
as a fan so yeah it's like the I mean it
first became a sponsor I've been using
it and it always it pops up every once
in a while when you're checking out and
so it's always just a couple bucks
so rewarding though
you like it is I feel like I worked for
it yeah yeah for sure
remember honey doesn't just work on
desktop it works on your iPhone too just
activated on Safari on your iPhone your
phone and save on the go if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show which we love thank you I use
honey I love honey get honey for free at
joanhoney.com H3 thank you thank you to
honey
hey be
and stamps
we all need stamps we all got a mail
stuff
and let's be honest with the holiday
coming up
with all the insane hubbub we're gonna
have to deal with the post office the
chaos
and if you're not already planning
you're already fallen behind but luckily
stamps.com has already got you covered
to make your life a whole lot easier
it's the 24 7 post office that you can
access from anywhere there's no lines no
traffic
and no hassle and what's even better
about stamps.com is
cheaper they get huge discounts because
they are this they order in bulk right
and that's how it works with a lot of
these shipping companies you can
negotiate down the prices you know for
example USPS and UPS rates they get up
to 86 off oh my God
so if you're not using Samsung I'm not
only wasting your time you're wasting
your money too
uh Samsung conference postage wherever
you do business all you need is a
computer and a printer and if you if you
uh need a package pickup you can usually
schedule it through your stamps.com dish
dashboard rates are consistently
changing with samsung.com switch and
save feature you can easily compare
carriers rates so you know you're
getting the best deal every time and if
you're running an online store
stamps.com Works seamlessly with all
major shopping carts and marketplaces
it's so it works so easy basically you
get a digital scale that they send you
you go online you weigh the the package
or envelope and it tells you the exact
amount of postage you need to print it
put it on and then here's my favorite
part you leave it on the door you put it
in the mailbox they come and get it
from your house
it's insanely convenient one of the best
services around go ahead and get ahead
of the holiday chaos this year with
stamps.com sign up with promo code H3
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
they say postage is as good as cash
isn't that right you can use posts you
can use stamps as money in this country
technically I think that may be true
still yeah it wasn't the old west when
uh those photos were taken at least
just go to stamps.com Click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code H3
thank you
stamps.com yeah
[Music]
and finally everyone's favorite
hellofresh fupa Troopers love hellofresh
because they deliver
home cooked delicious meals fresh legit
yes yes yes we love it
hey did you know you go to
hellofresh.com
h3tv65 and use the code H3 tv65 you get
65 off wow no plus free shipping free
shipping y'all
free shipping goal
it's almost that holiday season to be
pumping that song I can't wait I can't
wait
guys hellofresh is
such a great service
they they deliver farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes right to your doorstep let's
skip the trip to the grocery store and
count on hella fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit folks check out some of these
these are all photos
submitted by fupa Troopers
these are not you know
these are not like promotional photos
these are real deal scroll down
what's that one this one why would you
include that it's like it's just a
burrito this is the real deal are you
talking about this one or
I don't know anyway uh hellofresh guys
if you subscribe to hellofresh and check
save money off your fall to-do list
hellofresh is actually even 25 cheaper
than take out and less expensive than
grocery shopping too because
you get exactly what you need
and you don't have to throw out the 10
pounds of celery what's the deal with
celery like honestly what is the deal
with Celery Man sell it and massive
quantities nobody used that much celery
insane so wasteful awful I mean I'm
right right yeah you literally only use
one stalk of celery it's absurd
but hellofresh you get eliminating that
celery waste God forbid I mean there's
people in it there's hungry people that
would have eaten that celery
can you imagine just giving homeless
people a celery to munch on
bro
that shit's barely edible like raw like
the most non-food food food ever yo
homie Merry Christmas here's some celery
munch on some water here you go we got
some leftovers we only needed one stick
um yeah hella fresh rules man
it's fun it's easy the meals are always
delicious and fresh you learn about
cooking if you don't know how to cook
it's great it's just super fun and as I
said go to hellofresh.com h3tv65 and use
the code h3tv65 for 65 percent off plus
free shipping what a deal that's
America's number one meal kit hellofresh
thank you thank you all right yes yes
[Music]
purchase some celery ah yes
uh-huh
crunching some celery people
well lots of people defending celery oh
and chat it's soft guys I'm you're
really defending raw celery by itself
that's hilarious water get the [ __ ] out
that's a hilarious that's the most
hilarious food you could give a homeless
person
straight up like what's funnier than
that
iceberg lettuce maybe lettuce is more
edible than celery
just a full set of cabbage
raw cabbage here you go bro not even
cabbage like Iceberg like just I don't
know cat iceberg is more edible in my
opinion than just like a [ __ ] head of
cabbage to just hear munch on this
cabbage like has some nutritional value
though right like not a ton but like
there's like something in it iceberg
lettuce is just like empty cucumbers are
the highest water content of any food so
maybe it's substantial enough that like
yeah cucumbers got like yeah really
cucumber yeah of any food yeah I said
what food has the most water quantity
cucumber wait what about watermelon or
corn you would think corn
corn yeah corn check for corn somebody
checked for corn wait why corn corn has
a lot of water in it
okay there's many crops I mean but wait
where's watermelon on that list because
that [ __ ] are watery dude
Corn's water content is 32 I guess I was
wrong what that egg water gone done bro
corn seems pretty dense watermelon is 90
so cucumber takes the gold what is
cucumbers percentage 96. what yeah what
need that much water
ask God I don't know yeah that's on God
and that's on God what are you doing up
there God you're making food that's 96
Waters Shenanigans dumbass idiot [ __ ]
what an idiot God is [ __ ] dumbass
dude stupid you forgot to put more [ __ ]
in it idiot man of God water
all right so let's get back to the good
stuff here the rock is about to eat your
baby now what I was saying is that I'm
tend to be alone on this but I really
don't like the Rock and I'll tell you
why
shut up [ __ ] yeah exactly one I love
that sound bite
uh I don't like that he's in every
[ __ ] thing it's like the Ryan
Reynolds thing I used to like Ryan
Reynolds but you start putting him in
every [ __ ] thing and I want to see
someone else in a movie man it's not
even his fault it's like I just want to
see someone else why they keep putting
the same [ __ ] people in movies and
they keep playing themselves it's not
like The Rock has this great range as an
actor he plays the same [ __ ] same with
Ryan Reynolds he plays the same [ __ ]
character in every movie and he's in
every movie
I'm like God damn bro
it's not nothing personal against The
Rock but like
[ __ ]
am I wrong no I feel you
he's like the action hero of this
generation but I like when Arnold was
the dude
here's the thing about Arnold that dude
Arnold had
who is my daddy such a range bro I'll be
straight up he was the action star but
he had range you ever seen uh the one
where he got pregnant Dan
Danny DeVito
that guy's got chops
I think the big difference between the
Rock and Arnold is really just that
Arnold was fortunate enough I don't know
if it was that his agent was really good
or it was just the era that he blew up
in but he's in so many really [ __ ]
good movies and the Rock is in the dog
[ __ ] movie every movie he's in sucked
yeah everyone like if the rock had been
in Terminator and [ __ ] Total Recall
and like all these like because they're
Conan dude because the rock is such he's
such an egomaniac you can tell he
refuses to play a bad guy he has to play
the good guy every [ __ ] time and in
his rider he can't lose a fight it's
like wait is that real yes I mean
allegedly I've heard that
but that's the thing where men action
Stars they have in their contracts
they're not allowed to lose a fight on
screen swear on garsh
wait I I love that
he can't lose they can't lose
like that's what happened Fast and
Furious he can tie he can tie but he
can't lose
there's an article The Rock Vin Diesel
and Jason Statham contractually can't
lose fights yeah I'm sure you're gonna
be making the best movie in the world
when you're being to the writers and
director yo I'm down to do this but I
can't lose any fights just to let you
know you know the hero's journey where
he always wins every fight yeah that's
character development that's a super
interesting [ __ ] story Rock his top
rated movie on Rotten Tomatoes is Moana
which I kind of agree with it's pretty
great yeah and his voice because he
wasn't in it yeah his his song Love It
can you pull up
um I want to look over his Rotten Tomato
uh filmography I sent a link yeah that
has like okay good good good let's see
yeah I mean Moana was good fighting with
the family what in the God's name is
even that I've never heard of that
furious seven this man's third up rated
that movie rocks so I'm just saying is
thought number three is furious you
gotta give those movies a chance this
[ __ ] been in hundreds of films
and Furious 7 is his number three
the this man only has two movies in the
90 percent
I mean that's an exclusive Club to be
fair but it's it's I mean I guess the
amount of movies that he does yeah that
is pretty bad yeah I mean
I'm sorry but this is all dog [ __ ]
movies and then look he only has
okay let's do let's do it like this the
only fresh ones above
60 he has only 13. the Jungle Cruise
movies that movie rocked that was a
great movie you know what I I did see a
movie on here that I like The Mummy
Returns he's a side character in this I
don't know if it counts but we'll use
the Scorpion case The Scorpion King yeah
yeah I love those movies he had his own
spin-off movie right yeah I wonder how
that one did uh that's probably gonna be
near the bottom of this list so he has
13 movies that are fresh and then
[ __ ] oh yeah okay these are all right
this man is the king of making dog [ __ ]
films
the Doom movie I'm just saying
I think the rock being in a movie is
always a very bad sign like if the rocks
in a movie you know it's going to be bad
it's gonna be corny it's gonna be trash
it's gonna be reductive Hollywood trash
and uh yeah I guess no argument there
look at this this is incredible
this is The Rock in four separate movies
look at this
this is four separate movies
hold on he knows what looks good that's
four separate movies oh one of them is
the guy from fortnite yeah yeah he's the
guy that's where he blew out
it's Welcome to the Jungle Jumanji
Jumanji 2 and jungle cruise okay Jumanji
and Jumanji too that's stretching it's
the same way because it's the same
character
you're gonna be wearing the same
different shirt though well oh he
doesn't even like this same style I mean
he's the character in the game I think
but it's still bad but this is hilarious
it's a contrast this list I sent
Arnold's top movies according to Rotten
Tomatoes and his are really high up
there dude Arnold was making classic
after Classic first of all yeah the man
made one of the best movies ever the
Terminator series first one's done
better in the second one I like this
effect I agree I agree this second one
is yeah that should be higher yeah
universally people say I think the first
one was just like first one's Still Rock
shocking yeah you had to be there kind
of thing yeah but the second one is more
more iconic I think the fact that
[ __ ] recall one of my favorite so
[ __ ] good and I think Total Recall is
one of these films that like gets better
with time absolutely yeah I think like
when you go back and look at films like
Fifth Element it's it's rating is so
[ __ ] low even though it's like an
absolute classic
Predator cult followings original
Predator is such a [ __ ] sick movie
okay it's honestly so [ __ ] good way
better than it deserves okay so good I I
have to talk [ __ ] about number six I
love True Lies by the way Terminator
dark fate is the worst sequel to a film
I've ever seen is that the third one can
oh that's like the really recent one oh
yeah so what they did is they they disc
like they uh didn't count any film after
Terminator 2 this is supposed to be the
continuation and like the movie starts
spoiler alert and the opening scene
there's another Terminator that comes
they had like a DH John Connor and Sarah
Connor and shotgun to the chest kills
John Connor
um and it's just the stupidest [ __ ] ever
[ __ ] that movie ruin my childhood all
right well don't play my Arnold [ __ ] no
I don't blame him True Lies was awesome
you know
commando's a goofy ass movie The Running
Man was great running man's cool
original Conan have you ever seen that
like the OG
first Conan movie no it's honestly
[ __ ] sick it's really good I think I
made a lot of thinkers yeah I think it
yeah I think you're right I think that
was the first movie ever did but you
know what even like yo Mr Freeze iconic
role yeah even though this the movie's
dog [ __ ] you're talking about Mr Freeze
chill out
I love uh Jingle All The Way number 32
Turbo Man why are they hating so much on
jingle all the way I like that it wasn't
bad it was a fine Christmas movie
Jamie Jamie Turbo Man raw deal I guess
Arnold did make a lot of dumbass movies
like this what does he do back in the
80s it was like gratuitous violence yeah
I [ __ ] tear out your lungs I feel
like I don't even know what that movie
is and then yeah Arnold was like
gratuitous violence and the rock is like
insanely family friendly [ __ ]
those Expendable movies are pretty good
too so anyway oh Junior what part of the
[ __ ] what 39 are you
kidding me right now well you don't
actually like that movie dude that movie
is Iconic
what dude stop stop it wait time out is
twins on this list yeah it's down there
oh wait twins maybe that's one I think
you're thinking of twins because that
had Danny DeVito too yeah that is an
iconic [ __ ] you're thinking of twins
that one is a pretty funny Last Action
Hero I love that movie as a kid yeah
that one always got pans wait I feel
like kind of unfairly I'm gutted by this
score I thought that movie was on I feel
like it's it's reputation has improved a
little bit over the years although it's
still not considered like amazing but
wait why did they play my boy like that
anyway I don't know so there it is Rock
sucks that's my thesis
I mean compared to Arnold the goat
and people just really idolize him but
anyway here's someone literally hand
crowd surfing their baby to him
[Applause]
I'm sorry but that woman should not
you just did you just hand your baby to
a stranger to hand him toe
cam what's up
oh never mind
I was just curious what if anything was
up back there
wrong all good never mind the Rock
kiss my baby like he's the pope or some
[ __ ]
so now there's an intermediate now Ethan
for let me see
how long have you been talking about
because you started before the break at
least 15 minutes probably 20. you
haven't shown the video yet can you just
play it I'm playing you play you're
playing it for like a second at a time
and then you pause the [ __ ] play play
the video and you're the one stopping it
now
you are the thing that you despise don't
you understand do not
this man you're the one that's [ __ ]
holding it up now bro
please
[Laughter]
all right Dan can I play it now are you
going to enter please play it yes do not
command
hold on pause it pause it pause it yeah
what's up I just want to be annoying yep
all right you know that was coming
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
foreign
oh my God don't grab that baby like a
[ __ ] Titan
yeah so there it is I don't I don't know
what the [ __ ] why I don't love anyone
enough to hand my childhood when I first
saw this it's such a good twist when you
don't know the Rocks coming at the end
because it's already it's already like
you're watching this video and it's like
what are they doing in this baby why is
the baby being like crowd surfed at like
a concert like this is not a good idea I
mean we want and then we reveal and it's
the rock waiting eagerly you get his
mitts on that baby
you got hey you know he eats a lot of
calories yeah to keep that physique
[Music]
calories yeah but this this person is a
human baby
is this Jesus this is some Dahmer
territory yo an entire baby is almost 13
000 calories you get down the whole
thing Taco Bell wait how do they know
that uh archaeological studies suggests
non-adults were also consumed I guess it
was a study on a tribe that was
cannibals and I guess they ate babies
too yeah and eating an entire baby
offers about 12 823 calories all right
you know what Dan I'm really wish I
didn't know that thanks Dan don't tell
me that anymore about eating babies
please
oh thank you for the gifted dummy
10 gifted that's not nice to say about
somebody that's the name of your name
I can't control my goo
no more baby eating facts please that is
surprisingly a lot though it's a higher
it's dense
I think the rock does it
yeah is this a child protective service
issue because I I don't know man you
shouldn't be handing your baby off too
first of all an intermediate traveler
don't worry I got it and who hands it
off to the Rock who is even a direct and
by the way this is at the Black Adams
Premiere another movie you know is gonna
suck bad
uh
yeah and baby will start to cry and I
don't wanna and listen I love kids I
love my kids more than anything
I don't want to hold other people's kids
it's like a liability you know he's he
doesn't want this baby it's been foisted
on him and I've Loved kids jumping on my
lap
wasted that baby he's gotta you know be
politician kissing babies and stuff you
know
the parent just like ran away
um it's yours it's like leaving it at
the fire station leave it with the rock
you know what the Black Adam Premiere
what's stranger to me about this video
is that he's wearing a vest without
anything under it oh interesting that's
true why didn't I notice that like what
the [ __ ] I think the baby was
distracting you bro like what did that
hell dude show off the guns dude you're
just wearing a vest brother and pants
with a drawstring under the vest dress
pants with dressing
I have some of those I can't hit on that
really yeah I didn't know that they made
those brother you're just wearing a damn
vest
you got nothing else on my man
that's a hell of a look but there it is
that's the rock he does what he wants
let's see if there's any interesting
Twitter comments on here
[Applause]
oh do you guys seen this fake uh rock
guy on Twitter
he looks and sounds just like the rock
are we sure and he's on
he oh yeah here it is
dude and he can these all these people
think he's the [ __ ] rock and these
videos are hilarious that's like so
clearly not the rock no but his smile
and his voice yeah I mean I guess is she
biting him yeah I don't know what the
[ __ ] going on listen how he laughs
Listen to Sound he makes
[Laughter]
I'm at a loss of words this girl just
biting his pity yeah dude he's the rock
trying to suck his energy he's really
putting a lot into that yeah girl you
got you need you need Jesus girl
well I heard the The Rock's tip milk is
like really good for you
high in protein another topple kind of
real that sweet meal so there's the rock
not a fan but you know nothing personal
it's just it's enough already
this video has been making its way
did you guys um copyright check this
because I feel like this is the viral
hog territory I did I did yeah don't hog
me [ __ ]
I hate borrow I know I was I was afraid
of this too with this video I don't know
why I'm still afraid they're gonna claim
you but yeah I'm looking at it right now
the thing is they'll let go by the clip
and then claim everyone who watched it
it's so annoying
scum they are dogs we could skip gold
after this so should we just skip it
let's just skip it it's a fun video if
you guys want to watch it but I think we
should do it you think we should watch
it I think we should just [ __ ]
until viral hog to [ __ ] off yeah let's
do it as long as Dan's taking the blame
I feel like every time we watch one of
these viral videos it always gets
claimed by the Hogs by
we'll just contest him I'll probably get
overturned it almost always does it
would but it's the whole contestion
thing is annoying because it takes like
months literally for it to go through
but it doesn't we don't lose any Revenue
during that theoretically it's just like
an escrow who really even knows what
happens when that you don't trust them
they don't like I've asked my my partner
manager I've asked people higher up
I go okay so you have this escrow
account
so when does the escrow account get
released to me
what happens to the money from before
the escrow account right
if you they if you lose right what
happens to the money before and they
just said they don't know well they'll
go we'll look into that and they never
get back to me okay what does Susan say
yeah why don't you just call up here it
doesn't know anything
she says what's that escrow account he
said okay Susan
[Music]
yeah so one thing to point out first is
are the deer trips
everybody's so incompetent and helpless
in this video their trips
idiot
[Music]
you know what listen don't watch it I'm
over it
it sounds so much worse than what it is
it's not bad at all yeah funny nobody
gets hurt yeah it's just whatever y'all
can watch viral videos on
uh something hilarious.com or whatever
the [ __ ] there are no probably funny
this is a little William John this isn't
Ray William Johnson [ __ ]
this is H3 yes thank you do I look like
Ray William Johnson
a little bit
I'm kidding you know Ray William
Johnson's besties with Jeff Dunham
I did not know that I've seen them
together
that's weird and then what's his name
was friends with Kyle Rittenhouse um
yeah these old uh OG YouTubers
new friends Jeff Dunham Ray William
Johnson I gotta find these they did a
bunch of photos together they're like
Buddies
here they are man
here it is the comedy uh Triad nice
boy
I've never spanned so much fun in fact
in the one photo by
tell you what
um
ain't nobody funnier than that bar yo I
saw
somebody posts like an ad for uh
Jeff Dunham like upcoming thing and I
think he's uh
I think he's leaning into like [ __ ]
cancel culture type uh comedy Now
[ __ ]
oh yeah that's awesome
exactly what we need from Jeff
yeah he's on tour yeah here it is here's
my oh he's gonna have like a blue hair
his Jeff Jeff Dunham's still not
canceled bro are you serious that you're
still putting canceled in
your ventriloquist dude your shit's not
edgy at all you're a ventriloquist
you're a [ __ ] controlled dummies
like two years ago putting canceled in
your special title was cringe
still not canceled
[Music]
um
that's right have Molina get you tickets
though
I wouldn't be down for someone to go and
report on it
that's almost like punishment
I wouldn't want to sit there if you get
mad at somebody on the show you should
assign them to go to a Jeff Dunham
standard wait like comedy show let's go
who wants to go see Jeff Dunham I'll go
if Ian goes with me
if if we go to that can we get Terry
fader tickets as well yeah they're
ventriloquist dude we got Jeff Dunham
fans in the office that was happening do
you like puppets Dunham heads just get
done heads yeah go and get the worst
tickets I'm not trying to spend money on
the worst tickets I just think put them
in the nosebleeds as a middle eastern
man as an Arab man it'd be funny to see
a white man have a a dead uh
terrorist puppet and then see what he
says and you know I think the audience
would reject you we don't want none of
your con around here oh that's why I'm
perfect I blend in arlena we don't want
none of your con around here oh Elena's
not getting through the door hey do an
extra search on them
ain't no having no bombs going on here
today boy
still ain't canceled
still ain't blowed up
Lena's middle name's Ahmed that's a
problem
that's a problem ain't no achman's
allowed in here boy
it's so [ __ ] racist all of his sticks
are just like super racist I'm spicy
jalapeno
I'm like that's literally out that's the
joke he has a [ __ ] puppet that's a
spicy jalapeno Amy spicy jalapeno I
don't work senior Dunham I like to sleep
all day
hey
Mr Dunham
I come in illegally to the country and
rape young white girls
that's one of his bits super
controversial
still not canceled though
I like to rape white women with my spicy
jalapeno
yes Mr denim
one of y'all going to see Jeff Dunham
I'm serious get tickets for that Dan get
two of the worst tickets okay and send
one all right let's see well hopefully
they're coming to LA but Ian I think
that would be a fun opportunity for you
and maybe a b or whoever to go and you
can make a whole segment out of it what
do you think what do you think again I I
don't know how I ended up
there it's just like immediately wow
because when we did the last segment at
the crypto concert it was the first time
me and Ian spent some real bonding time
alone so it was nice I enjoyed it I just
want to spend some time with Ian I see
okay
I'm roping you in Ian because I want you
to make a fun segment out of it well I I
kind of got the uh vibe that Zach
kind of Might wanna go
like no I'm a Terry fader guy that's
exactly why Zach can't go do you
understand
you don't want them to have too much fun
no okay I'm a Terry fader then it's a
reward
yeah
is there any white women in the audience
today
um
spicy jalapeno will be raping all these
single white women it sounds like you
know all those jokes Ethan are you a fan
well you fan
I'm just assuming you know I'm just
using my imagination
hey hey my name is Ahmed the under
terrorist where's the nearest synagogue
I'm telling you man these are this is
his [ __ ] he does bro he's not
coming to California oh he knows his
audience that motherfucker's not even
coming to our state road trip Ian mean
you wait I mean I'm sure he has plenty
of fans here but um yeah and a lot of
the state I don't know it's just I guess
it's an East Coast tour it's like all
east coast and South
you want to fly somebody out to uh let's
see we're the closest one is uh I want
to see if he has any other Arabs in the
crowd if he's performing in Michigan
near Dearborn which has the highest
population right yeah I don't see is he
doing in New York City or any other lib
Bastion uh I think I did see New York
yeah New York City
uh maybe not New York City Albany a a
spicy jalapeno yeah yeah yeah
oh Grand Rapids Michigan
yeah
all right thank you Ahmed uh moving on
oh he's doing some in Vegas that's close
enough we could send somebody
oh great we can make a trip out of it
yeah bro that's not an East Coast thing
he knows his audience his ass isn't
enter in California there's way too many
Mexicans here for his ass he get mobbed
on the street talking [ __ ] like that
uh according to Kylie Waits and fish guy
got indicted on a felony
according to TMZ
so that's pretty interesting next
segment yes thank you all right now it's
time for Steve wiljerka you guys ready
for this adventure oh that is correct
indicted on multiple felonies you know
pull it up let's just let's talk about
that okay
Waits and fish guy he was caught
cheating
by brazenly putting a ton of weights
in the fish you he probably wouldn't
have got caught if he wasn't so greedy
put so much [ __ ] weights in that
[ __ ] and chit and fillets
man's out of control
scales of Justice are coming down on
weights on fish boy
he's in dotting on multiple fail news
now bar
give him the [ __ ] death penalty
I don't believe in the death penalty but
for this
man who seemingly won a fishing contest
by stuffing their catch with weights
death
just got nailed with multiple felonies
Jacob and Chase were just indicted for
multiple grand theft and possessing
criminal tools both felonies
they've been charged with misdemeanors
for unlawfully owning wild animals what
okay now they're stretching it
these the men are being put to sentenced
to death by hanging
in December of this year
we gonna have a good old hanging bars we
should take the weights he stuffed in
the fish and tie it to his legs
that sounds like a good old town I
really hate to say this I I think
there's someone hanging right there
oh no hey what would what does Logan
Paul saying at the public execution of
Jacob and Chase I really hate to say
this I think there's someone hanging
right there bingo
[Music]
woohoo
oh you like to catch fish then we're
gonna tie waste you and throw you in the
ocean
that's how we do Texas Justice why we
got Wings we kill them first and that
God sort them out oh wait
until it gets hot in Texas let's talk
about Steve wiljerk it this man [ __ ]
his dog let's just start by saying well
not [ __ ] well jerks him off for example
relations with his dog
he makes him nuts yes so yeah yeah Steve
has sexual relations with his dog
let's just put that out there right from
the start you know
um
so this whole interview is awesome he
goes on Bradley Martin's show
you know who I've been trying to squash
the beef with because I'll be honest
Bradley Martin seems like a yeah he
actually seems like a nice guy
and you know we we disagreed on the
covet thing
um but but he he seems actually like a
sweet guy
we reached out to him and we never heard
back never heard back oh that's okay he
doesn't need to talk to us
I'd love to talk to you though Brad if
you want to hook up
be homies
yeah wait so your best together boy I
think you I think you should try and
mend the fence by um
going to his gym have him train you oh
[ __ ] yeah I think I don't know because
he's so in so tight with dudes like
Steve they might see that as a I think
that's what it is he's his own man he
can make his own decisions no but come
on you know what it's like the boys are
tight he can't be hanging out they just
you know they just made him the head of
that podcast too now that the other dude
is gone oh he's on the he's on the milk
Pub yeah he replaced uh he replaced the
guy there dry mouth yeah
wow okay wow good for Bradley I mean
that's a big opportunity for him he's
not gonna [ __ ] that up
pump some iron with me get that
um
but anyway there's a lot to talk about
here but let's just cut first of all to
what he said
first of all here
question because a lot of people are
asking they're like Steve he's not he's
like he doesn't have all the money
anymore because you know you don't have
the gambling stuff like a lot of people
talk about you dude they're like there's
they chirp and I hear it and I see it on
the internet and they they're like
what's going on dude I I have one answer
to anyone especially that
dude there's this guy H3 that is just oh
he doesn't want to say my name it's like
that huh yeah you like Voldemort well I
get that I have people like that in my
life where you're just like you say
their name they they take it in you give
him a you gave him an inch they take a
mile right
or five percent they take you're getting
five percent they want the whole pie
yeah but you know he's right I guess if
he didn't say my name I wouldn't be
having yeah I mean he's right gonna say
it 100 right yeah he's definitely right
it's the title of the episode he's in
the thumbnail although to be fair they
they put your name in the episode of
this as well
yeah I'm in the title okay so nh3b yeah
they started
literally me when I watch this
um yeah he loves talking about people
bro he loves talking about people polite
did he say anything about you that no I
ain't saying about that okay wait wait
about what no we do want to say it what
was he talking about it but you watched
this whole thing right
sorry I was looking up something wait
hold on there's this guy H3 just prior
to this I believe he was talking about
uh
uh his sponsor deals that he lost
because he got kicked off of YouTube and
stuff
oh they were having a whole conversation
about yeah I don't I don't care that it
died I'm trying to get him to lose
sponsors I mean
I don't care about that let's talk I'm
not trying to ruin his life I just think
he jerked off his dog and it's funny
that he jerked off his dog I'm not
allowed to laugh about that yeah yeah
I'm sorry yeah what Dan said Bradley was
telling him a lot of people are saying
that yeah basically you don't have any
money coming in this this and he's like
nah I still got money coming in and
everybody still loves me I'm good good
man yeah everybody loves him according
to him yeah and you're just the face
well the milk boys the no Community
still loves him I don't know
[Laughter]
we saw the comments on the episode where
they denied him jerking off the dog his
own audience didn't really seem to
believe a word he was saying they're
willing to look past the dog the
bestiality Steve will do it man he's an
icon yeah
yeah talking about people polite did he
say anything about you that no you're
saying about that okay he said he'd be
like truly believes that like I jerked
off my dog and he pulls off like these
young pictures of Donnie like back in
the Fredonia house
Bradley knows that shit's funny
and that's why his ass is laughing
now also I love that he's pointing out
the age of the dog like it was weird
because the dog was younger back then
yeah
what are your dog pedo the dog the dog
was underage thing I haven't jerked them
off until
that's when he was dribbling Not only
was jerking off your dog man you were
jerking off your dog before the age of
consent right well the dog's two now and
in dog years it's like 14 so yeah also
he went on his podcast and told a story
as a joke if it were a joke you wanted
people to talk about it because you
thought it was funny yeah what's the ish
right that's the whole thing that's like
tell that it is real because if he was
just trolling then it would be like haha
I got you but like now he's like upset
about it the thing that they keep
failing to acknowledge is that they go
oh I can't believe it's such a need to
believe that guys we keep showing you
even your own fans like 100 of the
comments are like you're telling the
truth why won't you guys acknowledge
that every all the comments are saying
that they agree with us bro stop stop
you know
stop reflecting by saying oh I can't
believe he believed that it doesn't come
on bro without acknowledging that all
your fans believed it too sorry love
were you trying to say something yeah I
was going to say your honor the dog was
of age
foreign
yeah it was of age because of a doggy
ears so what what is 18 in doggy years
well it'd be like two and a half or
something it might be less than that
yeah because they age faster in the
beginning oh so you think it's not
linear their dog age is like I did not
[ __ ] my oh well do I need to break out
the trigonometry calculator age
calculator yeah
if he's upset about those old photos
wait till he sees the video we made for
him
mm-hmm
yeah well he should have known where we
were gonna go after four months 18 and
if a dog is 18 and human years that's
88.
my
oh yeah he's trying to find out the
other person around hey what Amy yeah I
know that's over it but I'm saying I
don't know how to figure that out with
their converters
18 Dog Years bro wasn't it in seven you
guys know how that works with dogs
that's what I thought but apparently
it's far more complicated you've been
saying that it there's like a gradual
drop-off you need differential calculus
they age faster and then it slows down
interesting well I'm like a 12 year old
dog is not 88 you know what I mean like
a small dog that's 12 year old is not
they still have a few years left right
so it's not exactly like they are a
French Bulldog
and human years your dog would be 24.
oh we're just trying to they're actually
saying two years would already be 24. so
the steam might be in the clear we might
we might have exonerated him yeah so I
just want to make sure that Steve wasn't
also committing um
an act of child molestation oh canine
pedophilia but he's something
all right Steve go on you're good you
didn't uh you didn't pedal your dog but
you did jerk him off
oh my God hey say what you will but at
least this is fair and accurate
reporting jerk off Donnie
always like wait wait wait you're such a
loser is this recent because I listen it
was kind of recent because the podcast
but he's such a loser like dude like so
he he's such a loser yo broke hand me
that handle of tequila
what time is it 10 a.m I'm like 24 years
old and I look 40 and I'm my [ __ ] and
blood vessels are about to just burst at
any moment from the amount of [ __ ]
binge drinking I've been doing all day
bro I know it's not it's uncommon to see
someone with like that much alcohol
damage at that young age
but anyways you asked a question about
money you're talking to someone that
yeah I'm curious no but you're talking
to someone that's literally sold eight
million dollars worth of shirts in 30
minutes two million dollars worth of
[ __ ] Bradley Martin sure is probably on
that one too eight like like realistic
it's like where you're seeing Millions
go up like I remember that I remember
money's never were you talking about
jerking off your dog or did you so he's
reflected by saying he sold a bunch of
shirts I mean what are you doing here
Stevo
my dude a dart
have been an issue but obviously our
chat is shocked that he's 24. let me uh
verify that but I'm pretty sure
yeah I'm afraid that yeah all everyone's
like what the [ __ ] is 24. well that's
what happens when you live on a diet of
meat and and vodka for reference he's
six years younger than me so if that
yeah put it into perspective for you
guys yikes dude yeah I mean the man acts
like he he's talking like he's got brain
damage from a life of alcohol
I think he genuinely might like the
slurring that's going on when he talks
or he's always on something
well he did sell 8 million in merch so
it's not doing too bad right what is
your mouth [ __ ] I spelled eight million
dollars of shirts
like money will never is and will never
be an issue but why do you cool man but
why'd you jerk off your dog
what do you think people I mean
obviously because I think even Even in
our last plot we did you were talking
about you know maybe you could have
spent less et cetera can you pause it
for a second can you go back one frame
sure I just want to point out someone on
Reddit uh made a post saying uh yeah as
one register are these guys even wearing
shorts
they're so bad
oh it's so funny dude they just get
absorbed
Bosom Buddies
um
yeah but okay so I'm gonna jump around a
little bit I want to get to the part
where he talks about Ela so then when I
go back and rap to the rest of this then
you'll know you'll know why I'm being so
hard on him yep
14. yeah so
that are talking and some jokes let's
take a let's take a poll here
what do you think Steve
attack the two things Steve hits on
to get back at me
his mortal enemy
who's simply pointing out
this hilarious story that he did as a
comedian
about scooping [ __ ] out of his dog's
foreskin what's funnier than that
I'm the cool dad now he's the cool dad
now Brad
you go cow style he he follows the same
format as all these baits all these
alpha male brain dead himbos
he goes your wife is ugly and you're fat
it's incredible
it's so crazy how they always do the
same thing isn't it
I think it's happened like five or six
or seven times now it's also after he
goes on a rant about what a great role
model he is and how you're not and then
he goes oh and also ugly wife
yeah there's a point of a dude this big
this picture says are they even wearing
pants bro where's your [ __ ] pants
dude
you forgot bunny I forgot
I just rolled out of bed and walked in
here I don't know man
so here it is and again
this shit's wild man here it is so for
the people who take everything [ __ ]
dead serious to their heart like some
just chill looks like yeah I got jokes
um mad jokes h3h3 I don't know it's true
I don't he he's gonna take something out
of this and be like that guy sucks yeah
oh yeah that's oh bro I got a lot more
to say than that
is that what you think I do here I just
go that dude sucks
if you remember how the thing that I've
realized about that guy is like no he
doesn't work out so I can't take his
can't take it serious boom there wait
was that a jump cut there was a jump cut
yeah yeah which is kind of interesting I
wonder what they cut out yeah maybe you
see maybe Bradley trying to keep the
peace no Bradley's keeps it very very
cordial here oh let's [ __ ] go oh oh
oh all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
morning for leftovers Sam temple in real
this is this me hold that thought there
Steve
oh god let's talk sorry love
[Music]
no Taco Bell in Sweden huh it's gonna
trigger them so bad we're like here
talking [ __ ] about how he's saying
you're fat
and we're like let's bust out the TB
baby keep going baby
yeah
so his first thing is while he doesn't
exercise so I can't take him seriously
which is awesome
that's awesome that he actually says
that
is that a thing they believe thank you
Sam to his credit out of all the Macho
[ __ ] idiots that have come at you
he's the first one to my recollection
that just straight up said it he is fat
and I'm not gonna acknowledge Him
because of that I'm not I'm not gonna
take him serious because he's fat has
anyone else actually just said it I
don't recall anyone else just saying no
not in a sentence nobody will come out
and say that because it it sounds so
outrageous yeah there's like Tate saying
like oh why don't you work out I'm not
going to take you serious you're
overweight and all this [ __ ] but I don't
think anyone's ever said I'm not gonna
respond to you because or not take you
serious because you're fat
just saying
I think we need to start asking a
presidential debates if they if they
work out not much yeah how much can they
bench
Mr President how much can you bench I
mean this guy's a Maga guy how much does
Trump bench
doing like Have You Seen Her videos or
she's trying to kind of do what I did in
a way like do really cool things and
give back money and do all this and
that's a little more difficult than just
postings what other girls would post
stupid ass effortless videos yeah I did
this dumbass cooking wait where am I
thank you
better talking and some joke yeah I
don't know what happened okay so here it
is
folks for the people who take everything
[ __ ] dead serious to their heart like
some just chilling it's like yeah I got
jokes
um mad jokes h3h3 I don't know it's true
I don't he he's gonna take something out
of this and be like that guy sucks yeah
who cares but remember the thing that
I've realized about that guy is like no
he doesn't work out so I can't take his
can't take it serious can't take his
opinion seriously damn someone that
doesn't work out and like
talks down I'm working out can't really
think I'm serious that's when I didn't
take him seriously
I really never did that guys
can we move on past that
come on now
you were being ironic
when you said it I want to even making
fun I wasn't saying don't work out
and when they take it so personally
you know yeah plenty related working out
to laser tag that's when I was like I
can't take him serious
and then also the only interaction I
ever had with him on the internet was
because like someone told me that he was
talking [ __ ] about me and like in in
retrospect when I think about all these
things I'm like where along the lines
did like I ever just talk [ __ ] about a
random person oh I wouldn't do that I've
never talk [ __ ] about someone but but
then again that's their type of content
it's like picking apart but like what
you guys are saying it's a business for
him yeah like he doesn't have people
that love love him for him being funny I
don't think or him being I'm sure I'm
sure some people
nobody loves me
somebody loves you for being funny
why do they love me Barb nothing
not like Steve
we'd love Steve for being an alcoholic
well sometimes you know
he travels around with
known rapists to hand out money in
Brazil
what's his name the the clown oh yeah
that guy he just went to Russia with him
uh last month good buddy that a lovely
timer he literally was doing Russian
propaganda
during the [ __ ] War what a role model
there was some other Russian dudes while
he was already in Russia with six nine
who offered him uh offered the both of
them like on 95k to come hang out with
them or whatever
but yeah no they they were in Dubai and
then they went to Russia because
um
he thought it'd be a good idea for his
first video on Rumble to be visiting
Russia during the war and then he had a
bunch of [ __ ] because the war and
because of the uh the basketball player
what's her name that was uh
held there
Brittany uh
Garner Garner Garner Gainer yeah Garner
or Gainer
whatever people like him first comedy I
don't know maybe he is funny but like
and to me I know that a lot of young
males like me because I was a role model
young multi-millionaire doing crazy
things on YouTube hanging out with
you know being best buds with Dana White
bro this I can't get over this he goes
yo I was a role model I was best buds
with Dana White how's your achievement
that you're friends with somebody
not even that you are somebody that
you've achieved anything
your best don't beat my wife and show me
I know Dana White so I'm a role model
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
well the reality is I know Dana White
that that is the reality but he doesn't
say that he's best buds no he's not
they're really tight
him and Dana yo you gotta stay up
talking on the phone every night before
bed
I'm just saying Steve you got to sit the
bar higher for yourself
being friends with somebody is not the
Pinnacle in life
but like just doing crazy [ __ ] yeah I
was like I was like a role model because
I'm so young and everything
I just personally don't see that like
anyone thinks Oh I wanna
be a 300 pound podcast
I want to be a 250 pound podcast host I
was right on I was 250.
that's true
and to be fair he might be right
about people not wanting to be a 200
well just not wanting to be you you know
who wouldn't want to be me I want to be
you you want to be him
who doesn't want to be me
I don't want to be you I want to be new
I like I like you so you have to be you
that's right if I was if you were me
you'd be me you'd be the same exactly I
couldn't enjoy you the same if I was you
not be the same you'd be me
but like it wouldn't be different at all
because you'd be me
from a third party perspective here
I want to be me enjoying you
yeah yeah so I don't want to be you
that's fine I had to go to bed dead and
wake up alive
with an ugly wife and just talk [ __ ]
okay here here here here here here it is
podcasts
I want to be a 250 pound podcast host
with with an ugly wife and just talk
[ __ ] about oh he told dog his wife I'm
gonna dog his wife the hot dog bro I'm
gonna dog his wife
because she's not pretty by the way I
just this is his girlfriend no hate to
her obviously
not even going to comment on her but
just look at her face and see like the
the brutal chauvinism misogyny comes out
she's super uh thrilled by it
but what I have an opinion she's not
pretty like she's laughed like
again I would rather have sex with
Jeffrey dahmers than your wife
who the [ __ ] asked Jeffrey Dahmer though
like that opportunity it's never gonna
rise for you don't even have to think
about it you know between the two I had
two things Jeffrey nahmer would be more
likely to sleep with him so uh there was
that oh yeah it's interesting that he
says uh
he doesn't want to dog your wife uh and
it's interesting that he Associates dog
with sex
why is that well first of all I know you
wouldn't want to dog my wife because
you're into male dogs you I want to
you're like he's gay he's gay with dogs
he's straight with as far as we know we
don't we don't know about the other we
have to keep possible
yeah we don't know sex sexuality is very
fluid like that you can't be gay with
dogs and straight with people so who is
gay
I love looking at his girlfriend's face
she's like man
why am I with this for sure
let's call you him but Jeffrey dahmers
is way more attractive than your wife
that's fine okay that's [ __ ] that's it
uh every uh I can't even I don't even
know what days these podcasts not even a
smile on Tuesday raw talk I love you
guys subscribe to the channel
um if you're on yeah so there is the
ultimate my out of nowhere too like you
can tell
out of absolutely nowhere no one asked
I don't even think Ela was present when
we were talking about him
I think she was like the third time we
brought up the video but not the first
two or three
there was even no need to go there bro
if you have to end the podcast
except to prove to us that everything
you just said is wrong
you are clearly not a role model because
if we're gonna reduce
stuff down to people's looks and we're
going to say that that's important
you outwardly said that someone wasn't
which is
clearly non-role Model Behavior and also
all of your credibility has been
stripped because Ela is objectively hot
that's the that's what this just always
blows my mind he looks like [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] like let's be [ __ ] real it's
just such a crazy let's keep it real
that's a great just like you said you
must work out
I got a problem it's just funny how they
always make the same point is that my
wife is ugly and and
I just find it so bizarre
how did they how did they come and say
the same thing I mean this needs to be
studied this needs to be like a
sociology study into this
it's like when their masculinity gets
threatened which I think is what's
happening they're insecure
and their masculinity
it's like they
they outwardly attack
maybe that's their way of trying to
attack my masculinity as saying my
wife's ugly
they're not used to dealing with someone
like you they're used to dealing with
people who are like them who are just
you know very insecure and they could go
back and forth but when they make fun of
you and it doesn't bother you they try
to take the next low blow which is going
at your wife I mean and yeah I mean it
doesn't bother her at all you know what
I mean not at all it's just funny
I've never talk about my wife in this
contest it's just such a lose lose for
them I just find it so interesting this
is like the fifth time it's happened
like this fat
your wife is ugly
credit to Bradley for uh saying you
shouldn't say yeah Bradley's a
sweetheart that's what I've been trying
to say for the whole time you know sadly
Bradley
um he did leave it in though and left
debate in the tunnel but I I teamed
Bradley on that you got to bait the
views I mean if you're gonna give the
first part of that conversation thank
you for giving the second mm-hmm
also because he stands up and leaves
there's a little mic drop moment yeah
they would have just like hard cut to
like thanks for watching now that's the
end of the episode so
like also
what it says about him is that
a man's significant others physical
Beauty
defined him
it's somehow
and insult to him so how attractive his
girlfriend is
says how
successful or
inherently good or something he is right
yeah because in his framework
you know that
the girlfriend or the wife or whatever
is uh that's that's the trophy you know
you want you won that only only job is a
dating battle
I I don't want to like over cycle
analyze but a lot of times I feel like
dudes like this who are really like big
and Juiced up they weren't very popular
when they were younger and then they get
Juiced up and they get really big and
now they think they're like you know the
[ __ ] and then whenever someone you know
makes them feel like uh you know when
someone talks back to them says anything
to them they're very insecure because
they feel like they're the same loser
they were before they got jacked and uh
they take it personally it really really
gets to them
anyone thinks Oh I wanna
be a 300 pound podcast
I want to be a 250 pound podcast host
with with an ugly wife and just talk
[ __ ] about oh you don't dog his wife I'm
gonna dog his wife bro I'm gonna dog his
wife
because she's not pretty that's fine I
wonder if they're angry at her in a way
but what I haven't I wonder if I wonder
if he's angry at her in a way because
she like validates me
like they want me to be single
and unlovable so bad right because I'm
ugly I'm fat
there's nothing redeemed they don't see
anything redeeming in me so the fact
that I'm actually married
to a beautiful woman and have kids and
seem to be in a happy relationship
drives them crazy and they're mad at her
they're like how could you do this to us
yep a beautiful woman who's with you
before you were successful right don't
even I can't even say that yeah that guy
must say she's a gold digger right which
I'm sure they would that would have been
the next yeah yeah
so true
they're expressing their anger because
they don't understand me to understand
how someone like me can exist don't you
understand bro
I'm just a fat [ __ ] opinionated
[ __ ]
masculinity is not even real dude damn
I mean it's just a social construct
I hope someday
he becomes the role model he thinks he
is
and he doesn't have to resort to insane
unkindness when he tries to defend
himself
yep for his audience on Rumble yeah for
his audience are clearly impressionable
young men I think maybe you should be
teaching them something a little bit
morally better
I think um
he is very young he's 24. yeah yeah so
he I mean by the time he's 30 maybe
he'll
have to change but at the rate he's
drinking alcohol I think his
IQ and Facilities will be declining I
mean the man drinks a lot he needs an
intervention yeah it's worrisome I
remember he had the uh
there was one point where he was talking
about steak I believe or one of the
gambling websites he was working with
and he was like he was just saying a lot
of information that he regretted saying
on stream he was like drunk or something
we talked about it during the content oh
yeah what did he say he was talking
about money yeah I looked up on my
computer in a sec but he's always drunk
man
Steve you gotta stop you need a period
of sobriety in there
also he's famous just because he drinks
because that's how we became famous at
start I think he like drunk a bunch of
alcohol it was like a fast sugar wait
you're right and by the way his name is
Steve will do it so like that's your old
thing I'll do anything bro okay cool
I'm just spitting facts you know so
you're the guy that's willing to base
himself
for money or popularity okay AKA a role
model got it
pretty like straight up like
again I would rather have sex with
Jeffrey dahmers than your wife Jeffrey
dahmers plural it's so interesting he's
actually angry here and he think it's
just so interesting oh this way you have
to end a podcast
argue him but Jeffrey dahmers is way
more attractive let's say dahmers
Jeffrey dahmers why does he say Jeffrey
dahmers
it's weird then your wife that's fine
okay that's [ __ ] that's it uh every uh
I can't even I don't even know what days
these yes so here's the thing uh Steve
I'm a gentleman
and I would never go after your lovely
girlfriend there you know
who's obviously as disturbed by your
misogynistic comments as we are
nope I wouldn't go after her but I will
go after your significant other okay
I will
I got [ __ ] to say about that dog of
yours man your real lover
this is like kind of crazy I'm saying
this but
one for example when I jerk off Donnie
I'm the cool dad now I'm the favorite
for example when I jerk off Donnie two
you
troll where the come goes I jerk off
Donnie they just go you put on the glove
I jerk off Donnie or like you go cow
style jrh NBR jerk off Donnie
when I jerk off Donnie
like family friendly and [ __ ] uh and you
just I've been uh I've been like jerking
off that choking your dog out choking
your dog off chirping your dog off
cool dad now
wait wait wait wait wait hold on so
I'm the cool dad now
[Music]
I'm the cool dad because imagine if you
couldn't jerk off Donnie
Johnny Johnny that's [ __ ] that's
Dopey you bro
if I get in control where the come goes
jrh MBR
Donnie Donnie
Donnie Donnie I'm the cool dad dude
that's [ __ ] that's to open you bro I
jerk off Donnie I jerk off Donnie
jerk off Donnie wow
you know
it's a it's a real love it's a real
romance they have
I mean I'm getting away of that you know
I know it's unconventional but golf
Donny
there it is Steve uh
I'm much more of a gentleman than you'll
ever be much more of a role model
[Applause]
than you'll ever be
and actually I have a whole bunch of
time stamps throughout this interview of
really funny stuff that I think is worth
watching
just to continue the Steve
the Steve Saga so let's just watch some
more he he loves Jeffrey Dahmer let's
take a look at this a prank okay so
clearly you've been watching Jeffrey
Dahmer oh he's badass what what are
people what I don't know if he's badass
I mean he did some really like [ __ ] up
things it just they just turned it into
a [ __ ] like a like a TV show like so
it's like I like it it's not it's not
even like a documentary style it's like
a legit TV show I'm wondering does this
influence people to like I've been
thinking about this honestly like a
documentary is different but when you
make it like
what is it
documents trying to say documentary but
you know documentary documentary
documentary where's he from about
Jeffrey Dahmer's is he not American oh
no I think he just has yeah are they
just dumb
[Laughter]
[Music]
speaking idiot he's speaking Florida
Floridians
oh my God is it dumb or does he
understand
the star of a TV show now and now the
guy that plays Jeffrey dahmers is like
why are you calling him Jeffrey Dahmer
you [ __ ] idiot Jeffrey Dahmer's the
documentarian
well he's keeping on with the plural you
know bears photos dahmers
that dude I'm just like yo can I have
your autograph like yeah no exactly as I
don't know if that like influences P I
mean I don't know if it ever influenced
people to you know drink a few beers and
you know
what is that like he was so he crushes
it and he does it's called doing the
Brad the Brad what's the Brad it was the
right putting powder in people's drinks
okay I see yourself I don't know why he
just doesn't like yeah I thought we were
done with those kind of jokes man no
it's whatever that actually didn't cross
my mind when I was watching that
I think he was like yo that's kind of a
good idea that's super easy to get done
did that cross your mind when you're
watching it
like I wonder if this is going to make
people get down with this nah you don't
even think about it no
hey uh um Steve this one's for you
Batman bad [ __ ]
[Music]
okay that's the Jeffrey dahmers
Jeffrey Dahmer comes up quite a lot in
this podcast
I can't help it I'm I'm like people are
tweeting about this [ __ ] dude I honestly
Wonder like like I'm watching it and
like I don't want Jeffrey to get caught
like they're just go hold on we just
found something funny
you know how Jeffrey Dahmer took his
victims out he would crush sleeping
pills and their drinks
look what we found on milk store
full sand sleep full sun baby full sleep
never makes sense how was sleep there's
nothing full sending about sleep by the
way oh no if you want those the discount
code was uh Cosby something if I
remember no [ __ ] it was like Bill Cosby
straight up yep yep
yep yep that's not really Role Model
Behavior I don't know that's insane
Behavior yeah I wonder what you could
buy with code Jeffrey Dahmer
foreign
so it seems there are fans of anybody
that crushes yeah so if anybody is
promoting uh that I feel like it would
be this because it's directly linked to
Bill Cosby who people very widely know
his
his crimes yeah it seems he's he's has a
specific type of idol people that Crush
substances into drinks take advantage of
their bodies yeah he's just telling them
when you buy this you know what to do
Donnie don't eat the dog food
what a freak by the way if we made a
supplement which one should we make
because there's so much money there
what should we make a supplement of
turmeric turmeric powder
turmeric ginseng ginseng
um
[Music]
would you guys buy a supplement for me
I'm trustworthy
Foods I mean I'll just buy it away I'll
just buy it from someone else and put
our label on it sure
now you should start selling liver pills
just go head to head with the King
[Music]
how are you going to milk an oat yes
moment so funny he's about to him like
no but I don't like this is when his
dad's going down to the closet and he's
asking him to unlock the door and I
think he's been he's like what's that
smell it's all dead people he liked them
all but I just like to eat people
apparently yeah but anyways it's like I
just don't want to make it caught like I
want him to like I want Jeffrey to be on
top and that's from it not being a
documentary it's like a TV bro what you
said documentary like five times
by the way speaking of Jeffrey Dahmer
I was watching that and I always love
how
during the court case part of a defense
for someone like Jeffrey Dahmer is like
that he's insane right that's one of the
defenses
and they go we're going through the
process of trying to prove he's insane
and I'm thinking the man ate people's
hearts
do we do we need to debate if he was
insane or not I mean I just like the man
is clearly
insane he would [ __ ] people you try to
keep someone in a zombie State and
rape them for like weeks and then ate
their heart can we but we don't want him
to get caught not when we're watching no
room for the original uh full sunder
yeah that is true it's your Ozark and
I'm just gonna say it
he must have not paid attention because
he gets caught in the first episode so
watch it again
right but like do we really need to
debate if this person is insane I'm
sorry you know
you eat ladies and gentlemen the jury we
found heads in his uh fridge okay you're
right he's insane
you know what I mean and bears and
photographs
yeah it's interesting did you do you
ever watch narcos and Pablo Escobar got
killed don't care
um
close all this
let's see
Steve casually mentions how girls go out
to eat with guys for good food
there was you know there's a point to
where it's like everyone's hungry and
it's like how do you get food yeah so
what'd you do I don't get it we had to
we had the uh we had to girl it as yeah
oh you know how girls like go to like
dinner with guys to nice dinners just to
eat for free and get nice free drinks
which is [ __ ] but yeah yo that's fog
girl let's talk about these girls are
[ __ ] up they just go out for nice
drinks and [ __ ]
why is that [ __ ] how often does that
happen to you guys you know like the
people go out to dinner because they're
hungry he's referenced saying he's in
Russia he was in Russia with six nine
and they didn't have no money
um no Russian money or whatever so they
needed to hang out with fans to get
their food paid for
oh that's that's woman Behavior yeah wow
that's female bam
it's very common so me and Danny
I think we got to be those chicks like
what are we gonna do like we have like
you're hungry I'm hungry we both want
vodka what'd you call it vodka yeah so
at one point we had that we had to go to
you know we went to dinner with fans to
to eat food so you were you were left
you were but they were such nice guys
they were such nice you're dead serious
about this huh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
gotta I got two steaks we got a bunch of
pizza oh I love that he went crazy on
the fans dime
foreign
I got a lobster two steaks vodka
let's keep moving on it gets better
oh should we send this girl from some
Teddy fresh you think yeah to like
say sorry for your boyfriend maybe you
can reach out a little bit away from us
yeah you know he's a good boyfriend to
her at one point he says she's like the
baddest [ __ ] on YouTube these other
[ __ ] don't know what they're doing
but this [ __ ] knows what she's doing
she knows how to make videos this [ __ ]
the only girl on YouTube who knows how
to do videos yup yeah we'll get to that
what is it this Wiz ass [ __ ] so this is
that I believe this is the video we were
referring to where uh during that whole
coffee Zilla Exposed on the was a scam
and like the lambo or the Ferrari
giveaway
um
he no one knew if he was involved to
what degree but he was just like drunk
or something on the stream and just said
so much like oh I found a way to make
money I found you know that's basically
uh
if he ever gets indicted I'm sure this
will be the first video using for this
is like a crypto scheme yeah he's a [ __ ]
my two best friends own it bro
and they've helped they've helped me
make
he's drunk right now oh yeah yeah this
is what he said when he was drunk yeah I
mean
you guys all my money is not from
selling marriage
I [ __ ] have figured out
other ways to make money today I spotted
200 000 scamming you guys I can't I
don't do that right we're selling
T-shirts dude it's actually impossible
Oh weird because he said otherwise and
he said maybe we just bought in a day or
something yeah
that sounds like real muddy to me I
don't know
figured out like I've like I've gotten
Financial advice
this and that for my two buddies they
helped me out so it's like they own
wizard s like it's bringing down the
whole operation
this is the names of the two dudes
they've worked hard for that show it
isn't a legal Enterprise so we have to
be careful what we say we have to be
careful thankfully they have offshore
accounts in Malta
Curacao at these addresses yeah he's
gonna go into court and his argument's
gonna be I was just making a joke it's
just a joke your honor I can't believe
you were dumb enough yeah you believed
me and I'd [ __ ] around like that whole
time man
to wear it I don't even want anything
like Alfonso has helped me a lot you
know with some Financial Like Making
Good Financial
giftable Richard no
by the way thank you to uh Carolyn says
the Bears from Illinois Zaki it's beer
cheese and Packers over here
beers yeah
I said bear it's not bears bears bears
the difference between the Chicago bears
bears and beers yes uh Noah says you we
should sell hairline restoration pills
I don't really take those though you
know what I mean it needs to be
something that I take
uh
gamer sup pills wait me and Eva actually
had a really good idea
don't say yeah I'm not gonna say it oh
that's it actually say it I want to know
no I don't want to say it because it's
actually an insanely good idea I'll tell
you guys off the air all right uh happy
happy 21st to Taylor thank you for the
good dude
they will get it I'm 21. [ __ ] you
um
here's when it gets really good
Steve says
uh Steve says why his channel was erased
I was right but I don't think there was
people kept saying we don't know for
sure that it was steak I was right at
anything or even said anything to
deserve deletion yeah it sucks no it
sucks because it's like you got deleted
for we'll just say it we got deleted for
having steak.com on my second Channel
keep in mind my second Channel got 100K
views per video I had steak.com
in there but you're allowed to say
you're allowed to say hey I'm playing on
stake
hey I'm on stake the best gambling
website ever I'm on stake but if on the
screen it shows you plan having not
playing you're allowed to show on
screenplayingstate.com you just can't
showstate.com you can't show the URL but
that was on my second Channel like it
sounds like he is really familiar with
the rules like somebody explained it to
him hmm which I'm sure YouTube explained
it to him many times before they banned
his ass
yeah who gives a [ __ ] that I got 100K
views yeah it's not about the amount of
views you get idiot [ __ ] hard
stop drinking bro and listen to what
they're trying to tell you the reason
that YouTube doesn't allow gambling and
stuff I think they're so hard ass is
because YouTube operates in so many
jurisdictions state by state country by
country there's different laws and
they're all accessing the same content
it's unbelievably complicated so in some
countries or States it's super illegal
for you to be gambling so they can't
they got to be real strict with it and
you being like Oh it's just on my second
Channel nobody cares it's just so
unfathomably dumb bro
and you're super familiar with the rules
obviously they explain it to you you
[ __ ]
brain damaged Bozo what rules you Sons
what reels
and they deleted my main Channel because
of it which is really wax at zero
strikes and they're not protecting
anyone from gambling or anything when
it's like their Partners when everyone
you name it everybody and anyone with
the following has a [ __ ] betting
partnership
that's crazy rationalization everybody
who's anyone has a betting partnership
that's not true bud actually
uh this one it gets really interesting
he starts talking about his girlfriend's
sex habits and at one point she tells
him to please stop it's making her
really uncomfortable
so then what do you look when you look
at your tits like I got certain little
concerning of course Warriors everything
I love
it come on Selena right here come here
no we were talking about the way this is
introduced is so funny because he's just
talking about how in high school he
didn't learn anything that he's used in
life whatsoever Midway through talking
Bradley interrupts and sees his
girlfriend say hey come see it come see
it come sit and then he's like oh yeah
by the way she just uh Steve's like she
just bought a vibrator and she told me
that she uses it while she's looking at
herself and then the story goes from I
didn't learn anything from high school
to my girlfriend uses a vibrator as she
looks at herself hell of a transition
that's my mind I didn't know what to
teach you in high school they don't
teach you anything you learn a squared
plus b squared equals what I don't know
you learn all this [ __ ] so close
dude you were so close I mean you
obviously knew it
well I don't know
I mean to be fair yeah you didn't need
High School I mean it doesn't sound like
you went to high school
the thing that I learned from high
school that actually like benefited me
in the real world oh Santa's here hey
what up come on no we were talking about
how how I how oh on gopuff you can order
like sex toys what yo Selena Selena
Selena come on Selena right here come
here so we ordered her I ordered her who
cares no we ordered a vibrator she used
it and she says she masturbates to
herself explains yo wait wait wait hold
on Selena Selena please please please
please bro these getting way too excited
about this right
you look great you look amazing and she
looks at pictures of herself what are
you talking about I'm not flirting with
you okay here now you got a real podcast
very nice
yeah he's a he's a gentleman
especially if you're talking about your
masturbation habits
you can do anything to get more details
yeah wait this is so funny how you
always come in the pause with Steve
um no no you're chilling you look
[ __ ] you're crushing it okay you're
doing YouTube now it's amazing we're
proud of you
um so can you just imagine if I was like
your girlfriend's [ __ ] ugly bro I'm
just gonna say it like what kind of
psycho [ __ ] is that
it's bananas but Steve will do it stuff
that's what he says Bradley won't say it
no Bradley's a gentleman it's just so
bananas to do that wait a second
Steve told me I do get the vibe that
that
um
Bradley wants to [ __ ] her
but whatever who knows his story earlier
in the
in the in the house and before you were
here and I also drank like your green
drink I don't know you bought me one but
for yourself anyways long story short
Steve told me that
um you masturbate which is dope I think
women you know it's like explore your
sexuality do all that stuff it's really
cool God there's nothing that's dope
because guys all the time is like yo
like I was like Bradley you know women
masturbate right
he acts like it's like some new novel
thing like yo like bro I was like
I'm like I can't control my goo
he's so funny man these alpha male these
Bros fear guys they don't know anything
about women I'm sorry short Steve told
me that
um you masturbate which is dope I think
women you know it's like explore
sexuality do all that stuff it's really
cool God there's nothing that's dope
because guys all the time is like yo
like you figure it out it's like have
fun uh I just I was like
do you think that there's this news to
you that women masturbate okay
um but he said that you masturbate to
pictures of yourself this is
this true wait hold up so already at the
gate she's like this is too personal I'm
not comfortable talking about it
who you masturbate to well yeah exactly
right you go
I stopped masturbating I haven't
masturbated for almost a year and then
Bradley reveals that he's a student
[Laughter]
gotta retain that
oh God keep those testosterone levels up
see me is just another type of murder
oh I got Vodka my tick tock's over
let's see what happened
what do you guys think I got here today
no live access suspended hateful
Behavior dude every time it's impressive
I thought they're gonna report you for
being fat
they would if that was an option all
right I appealed thanks for watching on
Tick Tock everybody
looks like the stream lasted for
uh I guess it doesn't say hateful
Behavior though okay thanks a game be
nice if you guys actually
I got on to that but all right literally
eight nine months I swear to God on
everything I love no but here's the way
to God she told me that and I said okay
sweet you either is this true no you're
either like bisexual lesbian okay or
you're a psychopath and
I don't know
there's a psychopath but it means she's
like into chicks or she's a psychopath
and she's like I'm not an insurance well
apparently both those are dope nowadays
because Netflix you get I'm so this
conversation's so wild uh what what do
you think about masturbating to your
picture of yourself though just just
besides her I've never heard of such a
thing I mean no that's kind of a slay
honestly like self-love hell yeah if you
do it for you straight uh I think of
American Psycho when he's like having
sex with that girl and like looking at
himself in the mirror while he's doing
it yeah that's what I think of but okay
whatever you know God bless uh you can
get after it
and that's about it
um let's see
oh Steve asks uh
he asked if his girlfriend looks at her
tits when she masturbates
okay so then what do you look what do
you look at your tits or your face or
like what like both damn I feel like
that's like crazy self-confidence that's
dope
that's [ __ ] good isn't that a good
thing it's self-confidence it's a little
American Psycho though I'm not gonna lie
it's a little American Cycle you've ever
seen that where he's [ __ ] the girl
and he's like he's flexing in the mirror
yeah
she's like [ __ ] her and he's like
he's like this
you know exactly what we're talking
about if [ __ ] Jacob talks about
American Psycho all the time so if you
had yourself if there's a clone would
you just get it down with yourself I
don't know that's what do you mean
you're masturbating to yourself so you
would right or at least you'd lick your
own titties oh you'd lick your own
titties on you go like this
I could do that I don't know definitely
no but do you do that she starts to get
super uncomfortable about it and you
might as well like you're looking at
those tits and you might as well be like
they're in front of me let's lick them
or no I don't know this is uncomfortable
dude
oh [ __ ] this is wild bro
yeah and then um
he continues now he he's made her feel
bad right really try to get now he's
gonna compliment her by saying
his girl is better than all the other
[ __ ] and [ __ ] on YouTube or
something like that I signed it and then
the day I signed like the next day we go
to Russia and everything which is great
content we filmed a lot of content but
now uh she's gonna really try to get the
YouTube unlocked because I think there's
like mad potential I do too because
she's not some she ain't just some dumb
[ __ ] on YouTube she actually like
seriously like glows or like she's like
special on YouTube like the way she does
it I think because she was watching the
best person and being with him right I
think he's learned a lot no it's like
how to film how to be on camera like to
be fair this is something the best
Mentor yeah I feel like a lot of people
don't fully I mean you wouldn't
understand like being around I think
this is all just a boy so he could stay
on YouTube by being in her videos oh
interesting yeah that's very interesting
YouTube and like kind of understanding
like the the energy even the mannerisms
all that exactly like there's like
[ __ ] that I've seen because you've
been around the whole time yeah like I'm
just like a fly on the wall and I see
how everything happens for the past like
three years well there's girls I've seen
like with millions of followers or
however many followers they try to make
a Youtube and I watch it and it's like I
would rather be a guy going on a date
with Jeffrey Dahmer in the 70s in the
70s yeah I don't know why he's got to
put down every other
woman Creator he's just a little [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] dude I don't know what to
say I'm on episode five I don't know
that's it I'm out thank you that is
Steve will do it uh putting himself in
the bracket with
all the other Meatheads who have called
me fat and Ela ugly so one for the
one for the books there yeah and that
Hall of Fame
I'm calling you now I'm gonna run into
him in person you think so where I
definitely know I I know I'm gonna take
the sins for the show one day you think
he recognized you
yeah
you think he beat you right all right
all right
you think so I ran into ricegum over the
weekend he had about 20 dudes with him
and he definitely recognized me 110 wait
ricegum has an Entourage still he has
well he's with like some of the phase
guys like FaZe rug okay okay yeah baby
uh told me when he was watching he's
like dude I could totally take Bradley
in a fight man I'd knock his ass out man
yeah he was talking about [ __ ] off the
air yeah maybe he's like I can knock out
Bradley yeah yeah
he's like [ __ ] out of him Bradley would
tear your arms off your body yeah he
would use me like a toothpick yeah he
can Abe kept calling him like a [ __ ]
he's like this guy's going down man I'm
actually not working I'm actually I'll
joke I'm not worried about Bradley I
mean yeah he could clearly beat my ass
but I mean he seems like he has some
reason I'm more worried that like Steve
will do it it's gonna be in Miami or
something or I feel like we're gonna
cross paths sometimes
one event that I think we may both be at
well that's why I never leave my house
boy yeah dangerous up there yeah
just make sure Lena records yeah
Lena
are you here
cut to the empty chair
we got to make sure that she always
ready to record yeah yeah for if you're
gonna get your ass beat we better at
least get some content out of it
yeah of course Steve went on Dave
rubin's podcast of all [ __ ] things to
complain about being you know canceled
complain about being quote unquote
canceled for streaming gambling
Dave Rubin you're such a loser what the
[ __ ] is this whatever reason okay do you
know like David a wine glass with water
in it very classy
I mean it's basically because you talk
to a certain guy right
an orange guy I couldn't tell you oh he
goes he goes it's because you talk to
Trump yep [ __ ] it's because he he was
gambling yeah that is a big thing I
talked to an orange guy yeah and bro you
are you're on Rumble the conservative
sphere playing up that you got banned
for talking about Trump meanwhile you're
on Bradley talking about you got banned
for for steak you're a phony [ __ ] and
Ruben you're such a phony [ __ ] dude
he really loves things named Donny
doesn't he
yes what did what
what else is Donnie besides his dog
Trump trump oh Donald yeah there you go
good
very good very good
[Music]
I gave an orange guy a a nice watch yeah
but to me I really don't hey dude what
the [ __ ] is with that hat bro I think
you made your size down you ever seen a
hat sit on someone's head like that
yeah it looks like a hard hat
what kind of hats they passing out over
there Rumble man it's high quality dude
well God's name is going on here
I really don't know why I got canceled
because I got canceled for a URL uh to a
website the.com and that website you're
allowed to openly promote on YouTube
show your plan
I don't know why I got canceled I'm just
gonna say specifically why yeah exactly
yeah
yeah it's because it's either for
talking to Trump or specifically linking
to a banned website that I was
exclusively told never to do URL some
numbers and some letters in there it was
just random just words URLs just pixels
on a screen URL can't lead you anywhere
bad we're all I got banned for was like
electrons and protons bouncing around at
the end of the day some zeros and ones
you know how electrons and quarks they
sap in and out of existence
something's just like basically no
reason at all yeah
website on YouTube so I really don't
understand the the
true reason behind it yeah getting
canceled for a website that's allowed on
the platform they just don't allow.com
so it's uh it's very mind-blowing yeah
considering I've never even showed the
website on my main Channel yeah so Steve
now they've been banned on YouTube is
going over to rumble
this website is such a [ __ ] show he's
doing some exclusive deal with them
Reuben's on there
I was on there today there did you know
Rumble is public that blew my mind
they're public they're down 13 today
that's a tough day for rumble Rough and
Tumble Andrew Tate's on there supposedly
how how do you know I'll be crushing it
don't you need to have some company like
this [ __ ] just started
last year
they just be letting anyone go public
these days
um well regardless let's check out
Rumble so this is basically
Nazis and pedophiles right that's what
always happens when you when the bright
gets their own website yep because
that's what they are so let's see uh
Rhonda said this is crushing it here
um there's your pedophile box
yep
oh there's a dog jerking video wait
don't tell me this is Pro Rush a
propaganda
this is insane and can push put into
World War III
this is one of the more
perplexing right-wing things I'm
noticing is that they're simping for
Russia
what do you think about that Dan
um
well
Putin's government is a very right-wing
government they ideologically have a lot
more in common with them than
until recently they probably were
willing to admit and yeah I mean frankly
I think that the uh
Democrats didn't do themselves any
favors by harping on all of the
russiagate stuff with Trump for several
years which really amounted to nothing
and uh I don't know kind of pushed them
into being more like well what's wrong
with Russia you know they naturally took
that position because just the
accusations that were constantly flying
around about Trump's ties to them and
everything yo we're fans of war crimes
bro bomb those public out bomb those
public playgrounds and hospitals in
Ukraine
by the way is this something you'd
expect on publicly traded website live
stream replays being prepared
[ __ ] I just clicked the video on
your I appreciate that they're preparing
they're doing their duties also also
they went public a year ago and the
flare at the top is breaking Rumble is
now publicly enlisted on NASDAQ
yeah I looked it up you know how they
actually got on there quickly is they
did the move that uh Ryan Kavanaugh
tried to do with triller where they
bought an existing company like a penny
stock and then merge with them so the
reverse merger yeah drive angry they're
basically begging their the people on
here to buy stock so it doesn't [ __ ]
go out of business
so congratulations on Steve we'll do it
exclusive deal with Rumble
yes
Sports exercise and Nazis and pedophiles
oh and don't forget Lo-Fi hip-hop radio
gotta have that too
super good there's a bit of Hitler and
everyone there sure is there Jordan
Peterson
um
oh there's a little bit here Dave gets
uncomfortable pretty sweet nice to just
with the
Steve saying [ __ ] apparently be able to
upload a video and be proud about it and
go to bed and just know it's not getting
deleted because I would always go to bed
on when it comes to Instagram and
YouTube and just be like
[ __ ] like you don't know right you just
don't know and you're not going to
censor this guy no matter no matter how
many f-bombs he drops on the Reuben
report the difference between Chris you
definitely set my show record for
f-bombs oh I love you [ __ ] but [ __ ]
part of my [ __ ] vocab Reuben you're
such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Are you seriously complaining about
f-bombs you whiny [ __ ] God
he's so Despicable Me listen to how many
he drops after this
the difference between [ __ ] Chris and
[ __ ] you yeah
hey Steve
what you're doing is [ __ ] wrong like
you got to change it up and YouTube
never gave me a call or let me know they
called me the day of deletion and it was
a girl and
they called me and it was a woman and
they said I know they said the [ __ ]
they couldn't even send a man to call me
that was getting deleted and I was like
this and I asked her do you lick your
titty when you masturbate
and she told me it was making her
uncomfortable you believe this big this
[ __ ] it's all do you lick your teddy
when you masturbate
oh boy
yeah it seemed happy and I was like I
was with me and my editor and I'm like
we're like bro like she's happy that's
pretty much it like she's like that's
funny yeah two great minds huh
incredible things happen there it is
Steve will doink it
the man actually jerked off his dog
ladies and gentlemen
you think it happened I mean let me put
it this way if you sued me for
defamation
definitely wouldn't work
you know what I mean the judge would be
like well he's reasonably
concluded that uh you do jerk off your
dog thank you neuropathy when I jerk off
Donnie episode for the donut
so next up we've got um that's uh is 2
000 Mexican pesos which is about a
hundred bucks by the way so that's
actually pretty big
the pesos are rolling in ladies and
gentlemen
2 000 pesos I love Mexico such a sham
what's going on there with the cartels
and stuff it's such a beautiful [ __ ]
amazing the culture the food the people
uh just the the land itself one of the
most beautiful countries on Earth to
visit and it just it sucks that it's
become so dangerous from these [ __ ]
cartels man
I almost ended up there on Friday by
accident
yeah that's interesting yeah you guys
you didn't realize that Tijuana
didn't know if Tijuana was in Mexico and
so I was driving we went to twitchcon
and our hotel we they charged my account
and everything when we got there like oh
sorry we sold out they refunded me but
we didn't have a place to stay so we're
looking forever for a place and I was
just driving and Lena's like oh I found
a place she put it in the GPS fell
asleep and then I'm looking at the the
sign right above me and it says uh to
Mexico or whatever like I was right at
the border and I had to like swerve and
get out of the lane but you know almost
ended up in Mexico
you want us pretty wild you guys would
have had fun there though
it's crazy though yeah
I had a lot of like camera gear with me
and stuff I don't know I think it's kind
of dangerous in Tijuana these days I've
actually never been to Tijuana but I
know like a lot of people from San Diego
go down there on the weekends and stuff
with my name and all the wires and
equipment I had with me I feel like
they would have not let me in or
detained me they probably they'd
probably just give you a little extra
search you mean the Americans yeah
because the Mexicans are the one that
check you on the way in oh okay but the
Americans might not have been able to
get back
that's the hard part he might not get
back into your own country of birth
for your damn Arab
yeah dude oh man yeah
I used to go to Mexico that was my go-to
vacation yeah people are saying Tijuana
is dangerous right now
if I every time we wanted a vacation man
it was Mexico every time I'm telling you
it's so beautiful people are so sweet so
nice
and um the last time I went there I got
shook down at the airport
I think I've told this story yeah yeah
but it's just it just left such a sour
taste in my mouth and
it's just too much corruption there at
the governmental level that I'm I just
hope that they've
been you've ever that close to us the
Border
yeah yeah I had no idea yeah so you guys
did you guys like go there to like party
when you were younger like in your
college Years
well I was not close to Mexico where I
went to college okay it's kind of far
unless you go earn like UC San Diego but
a lot of college students do do that who
are who live in like near the border go
to Tijuana for the weekend
because you can because Tijuana's crazy
man you can get down with anything there
like you can buy over-the-counter drugs
you can drink underage depro there's
like tons of prostitutes there
apparently you can watch a donkey [ __ ] a
person there I don't know if that's true
but the donkey show can you jerk off a
dog you could jerk off you can jerk off
a dog there Donnie thanks Steve
yeah in Michigan usually people go to uh
Canada because the drinking age there is
19. so it turns 19 they usually go to
Canada for the day or weekend
yeah but God Mexican food it's so good
I'm not even talking about Mexican food
Mexicans just know how to cook broy
any kind of food there Italian
steaks American food anything so [ __ ]
good well any good restaurant food
you're getting here in Los Angeles is
technically Mexican food as well right
it's true do they have Taco Bell
I don't think they're gonna talk about
it they don't but maybe you know they
don't have Taco Bell but what you do see
is like little uh abuelas everywhere
making their own home cooked Taco stands
on the street
that just slapped so hard and I tell you
man the spicy there
is [ __ ] crazy my parents lived there
for a while there was a little taco
stand that was open 24 7. so when we
were drinking we go to this Taco Stand
and they put a little bit of hot sauce
on there they go do you want hot sauce
yeah
bro and you see I'm good with spicy I
eat the spicy chip I've done the hot
ones and all that it [ __ ] me up dude
just a little dash of this [ __ ]
God damn those dudes do spicy down there
[ __ ]
yeah I'm good on that
yeah love to our Mexican Neighbors
love them
good people man beautiful country
beautiful
twitchcon this is great
uh you were at twitchcon maybe yeah
that's why you went to almost went to
Mexico it was a lot of fun that's nice
it's really cool it was really nice
meeting a lot of you guys you guys were
all so sweet a lot of the H3 fans yeah
crazy fans are the best they really are
they are you forget how at least for me
like you forget how big the show is
because you know we're just talking to
cameras and you know we're seeing the
chat but to see all these people in
person like we gotta stop non-stop
really oh that's nice
yeah I love the fuper Troopers man
they're the best uh but twitchcon there
was a lot of Great Moments great
questionable
someone
this streamer Adriana
Chi check she's a chick you're quick to
correct me there Zach you a fan for work
no idea what you're talking about I just
I did the write-up yeah she's an adult
uh actress and a twitch streamer
I think she's really quite famous in the
uh adult can you send me a picture of
her face just like safe for work
ah of her licking her titty yeah I got
you
um I think she's actually really popular
in the adult entertainment world
uh maybe you guys will recognize her
but
she broke her [ __ ] back y'all
actually a lot of people got injured in
this ball pit did you go in the ball pit
Amy we were so close to going in it I'm
glad we didn't mean I've done one of
those before and I thought it was funny
to like sweep her leg like uh
Cobra Kai and I probably would have done
the same joke because I don't got any
new material I probably would have
[ __ ] Elena off by accident I'd love to
get a first-hand account of how like
unsafe it is but yeah this is her she's
a twitch streamer and a performer I
don't know if she's still actively
performing I think she is on only fans
but she broke her back in two places
um from twitch uh look what she said
God right there
[Applause]
I can't get out
okay are you okay
she's held down by the people
gravity no no she's fine no no she's
fine no no she's my girl why are you
putting your [ __ ] over the video the
[ __ ] is there a way to turn these off
I think there is no annotations or
whatever oh wait no those aren't that
those are the end ones yeah I don't
think you can turn off that there's
another thing there's a backup link a
Twitter link right under that
that's easier
yeah thank you I'll open that one I
think I heard Hassan say this morning on
his stream that he got whiplash
um from the pit from getting smacked not
from the ball the pit part but from
getting smacked in the face Hassan got
whiplashed yeah I think he said that on
the stream this morning
this pet it was uh so much damage yeah
don't go in the pit it's cursed
yeah
now she lives in the pit now I kind of
think
just making jokes so one more time here
it is she's celebrating
and boom
how could that even happen it must you
it's like hitting Solid Ground yeah so
uh apparently that pit
is uh like one foam block deep but I got
a feeling the next day was not deep and
I'm pretty sure it's just a concrete
floor directly underneath that so I
don't think the foam blocks are really
doing a lot so what's interesting about
this is
you have to sign a waiver to get in the
foam pit yeah which is kind of hilarious
right off the bat like can you imagine
if Chuck E cheese made parents sign
waivers get let their kids in the ball
pit
insecure from the top and so people are
saying can she Sue oh yeah
because she signed a waiver and the
answer of course is yes because waivers
don't protect you from negligence yeah
right they
were negligent in the responsibility to
offer
Fair protection then you can't
consent
yeah to participate in that right
because you're assuming that this thing
is safe
you're waiving your right to sue if like
a freak accident happens but it's not
really a freak accident if you have like
it's just two minutes two inches of foam
over concrete and telling people to jump
into it this backbreak is brought to you
by Wendy's take a break this is this is
another pit this is a smaller one
this one looks thicker eh it was a lot
smaller yeah it looked thicker like
deeper but if I was to break my back I
definitely would want to this one is
thick at all
yeah you can tell like that's just the
floor right there oh that's interesting
if they if you get like on a really
shallow one
you're just gonna hit the floor totally
which I think is exactly what happened
wow
that sucks she tweeted out well I broke
my back in two places and I'm getting
surgery to put a metered rod in for
support today send your support when a
range of pores and I'm definitely
feeling the rain right now last night
was horrible the pain I had I felt like
I'd rather die this is gonna suck
special shout out to the random off work
EMT who got the workers at the booth to
realize how bad I was injured and to
make them keep me still and calm me down
until others got there oh that's very
fortunate oh there was a update I
thought it was supposed to be added let
me describe it real quick
um
yes please the update
someone else dislocated her knee also in
the ball pit
twitchcon be popping dude yeah popping
knees popping and backs popping
I wouldn't
yeah give me the update uh maybe before
I move on here yep signs right there at
the center
yeah she tweeted this out I think this
morning or last night so surgery went
well she says five and a half hours
more fusions than expected bones
completely crushed and nerve damage to
my bladder oh my God
again in the near future no more
squirting probably oh no the pig is
trash
God why God
why I mean she seems at least on Twitter
I mean who knows but she seems in good
spirits baby sad everything about it so
that's good she has a couple more tweets
that she just added if you go back no
more squirting probably had some
bleeding around the bone but overall
doing good she said
I mean that's a loss of uh work capacity
if she can't squirt anymore let's be
real I mean not ironically like you know
if your honor
ladies and gentlemen of the jury I mean
can no longer squirt it I know you're
joking but even beyond the squirting
just I mean being a porn star that's
that's definitionally a
that's a physical job that she probably
cannot do the same way
why people like their livelihood she
just tweeted out 18 hours ago hey only
fans members my account was hacked today
so that's a break yeah serious
why are you why are people like this
also be very careful scrolling don't
scroll any further you are on a porn
stars Twitter account those top those
top two tweets under the one you read
already yeah so just be careful anyway
uh thoughts and prayers to this poor
victim squirtless victim of the ball pit
it's a shame and a tragedy this girl
broke her ankle in this clip to which
you [ __ ] suck
not only are you incompetent to run a
business you can't even run a damn ball
pit
Christ's sake
grab your pickle securely
anyway
are we ready
a lot of confidence
yo both of them got injured dismounting
that's so [ __ ] up she literally just
hopped down and broke her ankle
[Music]
those blocks need to
Burn yeah and not yeah and deeper like
this is yeah it used to be like Waist
Deep to work it's like it's like a pit
of rocks pretty much so you also need
like a big soft thing underneath because
if you've been like a yeah like a
jumping park like you'll fly through
like however much there is that's true
and the ball pits at when we were kids
it was always like some sort of canvas
like bouncy thing at the bottom yeah man
I love her face she's like did I really
just break my [ __ ] ankle
a lot of confidence from Orange
killer knew from the beginning he's like
yes [ __ ] I just want this
wow
like this is such a
blatantly obvious thing that's gonna go
wrong like how nobody in the planning of
this looked at this and looked like the
same day it's three inches of foam her
back there the same spot and then this
girl [ __ ] dislocated her knee and
sprained her ankle let's go
shout out the Levant let Lenovo Legion
booth
Lenovo Lenovo moment l
love that for them
uh someone else broke their ankle not
from the foam pit unfortunately
but uh
well that's no fun
it's not from the from the ball pit then
I don't know I want to hear about it no
not at all
you know
yeah it was weird for me because I was
loving I was having the time in my life
but every time I'd open my phone some
other [ __ ] was popping up about how
twitchcon was the worst thing ever I was
I was loving it we made partner right
before uh on Twitch so me Lena went and
uh it's like a dream come true but you
have to be a partner to go
um you don't have to be a partner but if
you're uh you are a partner you get some
benefits like going to this uh concert
they had like Megan the stallion there
was a few other benefits to being a
partner but okay yeah it was cool did
you guys go to the concert we did yeah
we did there's a Master Chief in this in
the crowd who went on stage with Megan
the stallion started twerking okay
fantastic great love that
my favorite moment however from
twitchcon was not the ball pit although
that was good there was an after party
by this dude named Hill Mike
Hugh Mike is a guy who was 7.4 million
followers on Twitch which makes no
[ __ ] sense to me because
I know that that is insanely High number
uh 7.4 million that's put you in like
top 10 twitch channels right uh love
yeah you definitely and I have no clue
this guy's never seen him
and um I went to his YouTube channel he
gets like 10 000 views per video
so I don't really know where
these subscribers come from but he had
an after party
and a fan of his showed up I guess if
you donated 250 Subs
you could come to the party
25 Subs oh 50 Subs
cribe
and what happened was so if you donated
50 Subs you could come to his exclusive
party one of his fans showed up
he had only donated 25 Subs
and they kicked him out brutally
for not for lying about not donating
more subs by the way shout out to foam
savings
for the gifted to get it is that our
Saudi benefactor
well thank you bro
the legendary
so let's watch this video that went
viral this guy is such a piece of [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
from my house get out of my house well
you're out of my house bro get out of
here take it how many was it 15. get out
of my house
uh he said he gets a 50 sauce but it was
just 25. wow
[Music]
look he goes he goes bro you sent a
payment of 237 Canadian dollars
so does that mean he did 50 gifted
though love doesn't that mean he did it
I mean I guess I I want to someone's I
heard this clip was taking a little bit
out of context so I'm not yeah sure the
there's context underneath what had
happened was
um there were just a bunch of Uninvited
people at the party apparently and this
clip went viral from the stream but
they're saying they were just telling
people to leave and one kid was like can
I please stay I just donated uh 50 subs
and it turned out that it wasn't 50
after he had said yes you can stay he
was like you didn't donate 50 you gotta
go no but listen to what the girl says
here
uh he said he gets a 50 sauce but it was
just 25.
wow
listen I don't know I think they're
playing around I don't think they're
serious really yeah
he's looking at his phone he's seeing
how much money he donated and he's
kicking him out
[Music]
hard for this for kicking him out
regardless honesty is very important to
me
[Music]
dude the guy gave you 240 bucks don't
know as a fan I mean what in God's green
[ __ ] Earth do you want from him did
[Music]
excuse me
don't leave bro
just lay down make them remove You by
force
[ __ ] it it's your Birthright to be at
that party
[Music]
bro look how much fun everyone's having
why do you want us why do you want to
stay there
look at the truly brows here
I thought that was pretty cringe
thank you for the gifted uh from our oh
hey thank you to Bella Simmons our other
Saudi benefactor actually thank you
Bella and thank you to one third Sam as
well another benefactor you guys are
welcome to come to my after party
anytime
actually only the 50 gifted not the five
gifted sorry but yeah just not enough to
justify yet spending any time with you
thank you
thank you for the good
so that's that pretty fun pretty good
pretty juicy pretty good
yeah all right I guess oh there's some
great amaranth moments too
um
he kissed the amaranth Pro she's the
best she's so wild man
these photos she took with fans or
something else here check this out
here's amarantha twitchcon
[ __ ] going on at the way check this
[ __ ] out man
so how's this work people are paying to
take a photo with her baby
yeah so there was like this VIP meet and
greet um you could pay for and then you
can meet any streamer you wanted from
like the partners I believe that's how
it goes and then you just pick which
line you want to stand in
but like there was one big line and then
it would disperse into like five
different ones and like Hassan had a
booth and then a bunch of other
streamers so this this man gets on all
fours oh ass really out there right
[ __ ] pants
wow he's gonna jerk off to that photo
for years to come isn't it
love him for getting down on all fours
though for her
actually he wasn't the only guy to snap
a picture like that there was two of
them
um this one was even in my my opinion
even better
I like how he's oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
I like how he methodically takes
everything off
sits down his homies there ready for the
photo
yes
[Music]
even look at her once dude I love it he
took it off didn't even make eye contact
got on the floor put it on his stuff
right
I love that she's unbothered by this
[ __ ] she's just like them this is what
it is
stomp on me Daddy
there it is shout out amaranth girl
bossing it through twitchcon
um Hassan had a booth there
let's take a look at his songs
um
is this how come it's m half M so this
is there's a behind that black curtain
there's a huge line This is the end of
the line where you pick which streamers
you want to meet these are like the five
different booths or whatever but this
wasn't his stand he had like a merch
stand
um that was really cool
wait is that him all the way up there
yeah here he is the next picture
I got it close up but it's funny because
people recognize me outside of his line
and then like I had a a mini like six
people taking pictures with me and I
should have set up a booth next to it I
was like yeah it's like you're going
like Comic-Con to get picture with Vader
and you had to settle for a Storm
Trooper right
shout out Hassan very popular there at
twitchcon oh yeah he's a popular twitch
streamer our uh
our very own Hassan [ __ ]
how about that
damn it didn't it you're like obsessed
with saying that lately well I am
English in it is the new a yeah you used
to be Canadian England yeah you're
working your way through the
Commonwealth
um you actually ran into ricegum I
thought that was interesting here it is
we literally just got out of the car
so that's ricegum and FaZe rug yeah goat
cheese
so what happened here it was just all
happening too fast I just walked around
like was that ricegum and I was like I
can't just let that be what I say and so
I turned back around and I was hey
what's up man big fan I shook his hand
big fan and then I shook FaZe rug's hand
and FaZe rug was like super sweet and I
was like
all right that's all that's all I got
rug is nice yeah he seems very nice and
then I said oh and then I told him I
worked for H3 and then rice like rug was
like oh that's cool but rice looked like
gave me like the look at that oh [ __ ]
yeah I definitely have a storied history
with ricey boy over there also
interestingly
called my wife ugly that's right he's
kind of the OG yeah he's gonna maybe set
that precedent yeah he role model at
least he was original in a sense then
well not really keemstar kind of started
the Monica over here and he had a diss
track where he said you're lame and
you've gained weight
so yeah he's wow he's a trendsetter
trendsetter shout out
that was the only time I've ever made a
diss track so I came hard for my boy
rice
he went back shook his hand
thank you oh he didn't look happy at all
right see Rice-A-Roni yeah
the San Francisco tree rug looks sweet
look at him yeah rice is having a good
time he's throwing you a piece I'm just
happy to be here right here rug is a
nice guy I spent the next day with
idubbbz for a lot of the day and I was
like man I wish I could have ran into
rice with Ian on stream
level yeah that is an interesting thing
about twitchcon
seeing people run into each other that
would never really get along eh yeah in
it but after after shaking his hand
though me and riser boys I'm a fan of
both of them yeah
I'm a fan okay something about meeting
these YouTubers in person like Austin
McBroom you just dab him up and it's all
good baby sins are forgiven but to be
honest with you I mean he was cordial he
wasn't like a dick or anything you know
he said hi and peace and you know he did
the whole thing so
is that really him that one
yeah that one I know is him no those are
both unedited
come on that's him bro
this one's the best
so long wait play the one where it like
changes tone
it goes
again
oh my God
you're hot
we love you Rice-A-Roni the San
Francisco tree yes sir before we move on
I just want to show Hassan's Booth I
sent it and uh to support this Sean's
Booth yeah his merch booth in a photo
booth it's a pretty cool design yeah it
was sick I wonder cracker who paid for
all that that's sick I'm gonna ask him
on tomorrow tomorrow see what the
newspaper says the sun it's like or
twitch steals 30 revenue from content
creators
50 now
it depends oh it's like at a certain
threshold yeah I'm 50. I don't know how
it works though
I think it works like the more you get
the more they take right which is kind
of super unintuitive yeah
pretty much you said you guys are making
too much
totally you never know what you're going
to get oh this is super cool though
um shout out Hassan
Friends of the show more than front of
the show
it's a brother of the show brother in
arms of the show
and then
hey in a day
pull out pull out
oh another fun story
Logan Paul invested heavily in nfts as
you guys know
by the way how is the nft market doing
or is it in shambles because I know the
stock market is bad
bitcoin's number 19. I mean it hasn't
I mean it had that huge crash uh
probably four or five months ago and
it's sort of stabilized it hasn't really
been moving up or down for the last
several months I mean the stock market
seems to be moving down more where
Bitcoin seems to be more stable but they
crashed way deeper yeah because I mean
they lost like
70 of its value That's crazy dude so I'm
kind of at a loss for words right now
ethereum let's see let's eat that
1300 yeah
[ __ ] wait 13.
whoa when we first did our nfts what was
it at like 1800 yeah around there I
believe right no it was right around it
was like 14. Mark twelve oh it's so
weird yeah it was it was around where it
is right now yeah
yeah it spiked up to like almost 4 000
or something but good at it yeah almost
five thousand well anyway the
crypto Market is in shambles the nft
Market's even worse off
Logan Paul bought this uh rare bumblebee
nft for 600
.
it's not that rare I downloaded it 10
times it's really rare it's so broken
though I put it on like I downloaded I
have it on like 100 different USB drives
no no
those are the only 100 copies then
that's it yeah no it's super rare here
it is
uh at the moment though
it's valued at ten dollars so oh that's
a steal
that well that's a steal that that's
that picture is worth a million bucks
that's like 62 000 drop off I it's gone
up a little bit just because of the hype
around it being so cheap the story yeah
yeah
well shout out to Logan there he really
made a great investment uh although dink
dunk probably made up for an end
he's probably very happy about this news
coming out this is he's getting offers
for two ethereum now okay yeah I mean
he's which if he sold it
that's 500 above floor difference yeah
what's the floor
ten bucks oh my God
I can't play on the floor is what a
disaster [ __ ] all over the floor this
nft Market is
yeah yeah and uh I don't think we have
it written up in here but news just
yesterday came out that the uh board ape
Nazi Club dudes are uh being
investigated for Securities fraud by the
SEC so shout out
shout out to Yuga Labs Good Guys yep
Yuga Labs who by the way remember when
we made that episode about them and then
like all these [ __ ] dudes came out
the woodwork trying to contact me yeah
they didn't they didn't like that that
was kind of weird thinking back all
these Hollywood big wigs and like
shadowy figures being like yo let's get
on a phone call
I mean it was weird at the time
that's super interesting
yep
well yeah you know you can't win them
all but there it is who would have
thought that this P jpeg
wasn't worth 623 thousand dollars who
would who could have guessed that I
don't know
dude it looks so sick there's like kind
of vaguely uh you know it almost looks
like some sort of Asian symbol behind it
that's super cool like high tech
like you know like Chinese or Japanese
that's that's high-tech as [ __ ] that's
insanely good yeah like you couldn't
create this in any medium other than
right at all which is why it's so
valuable oh yeah bro hold on one sec
hold on one sec save his image oh Ethan
you're you're committing a crime right
now I'm like hold on live on air hold on
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] FBI hold on okay no
I just saved it twice no three times
dude that's three counts they're here
they're here
stop me [ __ ]
[Music]
I just I just made three million dollars
ladies and gentlemen we got them
yeah so my heart goes out to Logan Paul
there for that uh
huge loss of money yep damn tragic
tragic
uh Logan Paul also required Acquired and
this one's even better
Rock number 65 guys
take a look at this one
yes Rock number 65.
and 68 were acquired for
he bought this for sixty thousand
dollars
and he brought rock uh 68 for 95 000
okay yeah it's good now let's just let's
just appreciate if we can please
the Artistry that went into this right
okay
are you really trying to tell me this is
not a 90 000 jpeg
I would never Ethan I'll download it
[ __ ] your rock no no it's my rock now
[Music]
it's my rock baby
oh no this point one eth offer is
expired They didn't accept it oh they
must have been they must have been busy
[ __ ]
yeah so unfortunately for Logan Paul
um
who's about
150 000 in on these rocks
uh Rock number 20 a 65 is being offered
only 25 dollars
on open c
yeah
I would have never guessed that man I
would never seen this coming at all yeah
like I would never guess that man
a year ago who would have ever thought
that the nft market would crash
hmm
angry
oh it's so mad about it when he saw this
coming
look at all these rocks guys
oh this Rock's price is 25 nobody's
buying it though angry they saying you
can buy this for 20 for 32 000.
32 000 yeah that's what they're saying
63.
I mean that that still sounds like a
bargain compared to a hundred thousand
yeah why isn't Logan buying up this Rock
right now yeah
if he believes in the project that's are
you seeing that too I said that's a nice
one this rock is kind of a Vibe I like
that one dude this rock is kind of a
Vibe though to be to be true to be true
speak the truth there well though you
know it kind of looks
it's kind of funny it kind of looks like
it's uh flipping you off a little bit
you know what I mean can we examine
these rocks here yeah yeah let's let's
go geology mode they're all different
rocks
you see number 33 mm-hmm you see that
that one goes kind of hard that rock I
like how the bodies dude that would look
great on my wall yeah this one here you
mean your wallet in your in your
metaverse house right exactly right not
my real house nothing practical one I
wonder why 16 is more valuable than 91.
are you kidding are you blind clear as
day yeah
you don't know anything about art you
[ __ ] idiot
oh I love it didn't it took even less
time than I thought it would for for
this [ __ ] to crash literally nothing
Iran hasn't been on sale for four months
there hasn't been a rock sale for four
months yeah
because all the idiots who bought this
[ __ ] are like I'm not selling this I'm
holding baby
communities will do that like crypto or
nft communities they'll like they'll
think if no one sells it it's gonna hold
value but right obviously it doesn't
work yeah that doesn't that's not quite
how it worked wow [ __ ] dumbass Logan
Paul we're supposed to believe this
guy's a genius entrepreneur
and he paid 150 000 for two of these
[ __ ] rocks
I don't think anybody he doesn't
characterize himself as a as a genius
entrepreneur does he he's not like Steve
will do it we're like I'm a [ __ ] role
model I'm the [ __ ] no he's not that
insane yeah I think he's a little more
humble than that well he says his goal
is to be the biggest Entertainer in the
world so yeah but he doesn't say he is
what's worse suicide force or The Rock
suicide for us okay excuse these rocks
are Rock Dwayne Johnson oh Dwayne Dwayne
oh Dwayne no oh
my answer
I mean he does eat babies actually well
well the good news for Logan is that um
at least he's going to be able to
get that big tax break in in Puerto Rico
right right yeah
the rock loss here yeah huge Rock loss
um I think we've been going for a minute
you know we're about to get into
Olivia's segment meme history
put Lovato but I guess we'll hold off on
that for Friday we'll save it for Eli
you'll all like it
put Lovato I've seen the picture but I
didn't know it had a name oh I love I've
purposely I've I've been very hands off
on this whole project Olivia's been very
excited about it and I have not spoiled
it I don't know anything about Lovato
beyond the name it's a surprise you
can't show well everyone knows the
picture it's just the lore behind the
picture I already looked at the whole
thing oh okay well did you like it yeah
no it's great thank you but this [ __ ]
photo cracks me this [ __ ] tough I'm not
looking yeah
it's so good
so funny yeah put Nevada there it is
when Olivia said should I make a
PowerPoint I was like don't don't ask me
go ahead that's the the Maestro himself
it's a game of Russian Roulette
by the way this beautiful polo
that I'm wearing
yeah beanie you guys may have noticed
where'd you get it thinking damn you
stressed sharp today I've been thinking
that the whole time anyfirst.com of
course
Teddy fresh.com
huh never heard of them what's going on
on their website oh my stomach's
starting to feel [ __ ] up from like
Taco Bell
because I I haven't been able to eat
really
that was the first like meal I've had
I'm glad I didn't have three tacos and
two burritos
take it out guys
it's all happening
atstake.com what are we checking out I
mean teddyfish.com
you're gonna get banned
I like how he's like everybody's got a
betting partner
everybody who's anybody
got choices yup
hey guys remember
if you are a member there's members only
podcasts up
every Tuesday
see you next Tuesday
and s-y-n-t podcast your favorite
podcast and congratulations everyone who
got gifted a sub that's so cool I love
that
150 of them between our two
Saudi benefactors love them man I see
comments maybe they both shouldn't be
Saudi maybe uh
ones from Qatar or something katari yeah
I see a lot of people comment that they
didn't know they're a member they didn't
know they were gifted a sub sometimes so
oh yeah if you're on uh desktop check it
out see if you remember go to the
members tab I guess the way it gifts it
is based on activities so if you are a
frequent Watcher of this show
you're more likely to get the gifted so
uh yeah if you're watching the show all
the time check your dashboard it's cool
you might be a subscriber
give
give
it get get
wait do we have the ninja
the new ninja clip
I've been playing them all day I know
you've been playing them all day but the
audience doesn't know what they're from
oh you're talking the real clip
um it's just kind of out of context
maybe it is better out of context let's
just leave it that way oh we got another
50 gifted from Bella Simmons who are you
Bella
love that for you
thank you Erica
uh she said it's
her birthday and she got Teddy fresh
best gift ever thank you Erica Legend
oh Legend America
um
thank you thank you so much do you want
to show those ninja ones I'd like to
watch those before we go
uh
uh I don't even know I probably should
have had them ready before I suggested
that that one you could pull it up no
problem
the goo ones on his Twitter it's like
the first video
did I hear the sound
uh oh here you go of course Ian had it
oh Ian had it and the ninja simp in the
office
you want me to open it I got it here's
ninja drop in the goo
oh he tweeted this out yeah interesting
I find that really interesting
oh my God oh
why do you tweet this
oh
my
oh that's funny that he tweeted this it
didn't even get this ever since he left
like twitch or when he went like on all
platforms he's been a little bit more
cheeky dude yeah
he's feeling himself yeah it only has 3
000 likes we're the only one that liked
this clip but we're taking it
the podcast
I don't like it in fact I'll buy them I
like it and I'm gonna retweet it one
hour ago Alex Jones must pay
a billion dollars in Sandy Hook
defamation trial
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] awesome bro
Jerry decides he must pay 965 million
dollars
now is there a limit in
Connecticut for punitive damages like in
Texas it's limited oh I
I think there was
I remember I looked into all of this one
we talked about the first trial I can't
remember I know it's heinous what he did
but a billion dollars
like I'm on their side don't get me
wrong but like what do you mean a
billion dollars well I mean I think
everybody understands that that would
never be paid but I think the idea is
pretty obviously to bankrupt him and to
get him off the air you know it's so
funny a billion [ __ ] dollars like I'd
like to see the math on that yeah I'll
um we should talk about it on leftovers
tomorrow
um yes and I can do like a whole
breakdown on breaking news so yeah
Hassan if you're watching please don't
discuss it today
yeah uh wait till tomorrow morning I'm
sure he's probably been talking about it
for the last two hours it's not very
girthy
so wait what's the punitive damage Max
in Connecticut if you can fish that up I
just want to know how [ __ ] is he
yeah in Texas it's like very very very
very low damage is uh not to exceed
fifty thousand dollars what
well that's probably not all punitive
damages that's like a very specific part
of what you get rewarded
oh let me let me do some actual research
on it not on the Fly and we can we can
break it all down tomorrow why stop at a
billion let's just keep it going man
10 billion
because she said here I couldn't be more
proud to stand here and
with all of these people and
I really miss my wife and daughters
right now and they can't be here with me
but
our lawyers are you you're bringing down
the vibe dude I was gonna say this is
like he will do it mentioning ELO in the
last minute like we were so close you're
you're bringing it down I'm I'm on your
side by the way it's [ __ ] up it's good
he got that dub in court that's what he
wanted
let's get a billion dollars out to hit
this man font there
[ __ ] he's such a piece of [ __ ] though
and now that he's losing he's just gone
on this whole like [ __ ] it I killed him
[ __ ] it I don't apologize
I killed those kids I saw some clips of
him on uh channel five saying like yeah
I'm a Night Stalker I did this I did
that yeah I watched that
and a ding dong
is a sucking a ding dong sucking a ding
dong
uh thank you for the one gifted vertical
one uh and Derek runts donated 20. 20
gifted oh thank you Derek can I make a
quick announcement real quick Troubadour
there are only 50 tickets left oh wow
okay so uh low ticket warning there's
only 50 tickets left to the Troubadour
Troubadour there's only 50 tickets left
January 13th 13th 13th let's go that's
during our break interesting wait the
13th please don't do this please please
don't okay is it on a Friday no no there
was a hole cam put the accidentally put
the wrong date on the meme he made so
now that all the comments are just
[ __ ] the data you're doing it
yourself now well don't go buy the
ticket and the ticket will say the right
thing thank you yeah January 13th but
I'm I'm available on the 16th I don't
know if I'm available I'll be there on
the 16th
you sold the tickets it doesn't matter
if they come or not right that's true
it's Friday the 13th he's a showman
though he wants the audience the show
yeah that's how you can remember it's
Friday the 13th exactly for January
Friday the 13th the most the most uh 13
plus three is how much
maybe you should move it to the 16th
dude
what are you singing wait keep going why
I want to know yeah oh yeah that is
I Wanna Know
if you ever
just want to point something
the Reddit
um like when Hassan started singing that
and I told him about the curse it was
all this [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happened at
twitchcon and now he has Whiplash yeah
so oh so you're blaming all bad things
that happened at twitchcon
well he his song was fine he
specifically got whiplash from okay so
is that one girl breaking her back
because of the client no no I limited
just to twitchcon I mean lots of
terrible things have happened in the
world
I think it's left January 13th live
attributor see Zach at the mint January
46th yeah if we banned clydens Klein
water worldwide globally
would we would war and famine all that
stop would it be peace on Earth I hope
so
one can hope I can't give you the gifted
Indy I can't make that you know if we
were to ban CCR right tomorrow there we
go okay there we go there we are except
people are still walking around with
sleeveless uh shirts uh where's the
Utopia now the one guy there is not
asleep free to do that yeah dude you
[ __ ] that dog's gonna [ __ ] on the
floor he's not gonna pick it up it's a
robot dog it's a robot dog it doesn't
[ __ ] you know in the Utopia there are no
dogs would it be weird jerks off a robot
dog is that weird is that wrong
hmm
that's an interesting philosophical
question
is it bestiality I want to know about a
robot dog would you ever jerk off your
dog
I want to know would you ever scoop out
the car all right of your dogs three
hours January 13th that's probably
enough 50 tickets left
far and have my dog
all right okay yeah
this is like kind of crazy I'm saying
this but one for example when I jerk off
Donnie I'm the cool dad now should be
our outro song today let's watch one
more uh each then you hold on let's
close with this oh my back is killing me
I gotta get out of this chair this is
like kind of crazy I'm saying this all
right bye guys see you on uh tomorrow
morning for example when I jerk off
what's going on I'm the cool dad now I'm
the favorite for example when I jerk off
Donnie two you Patrol where the cone
goes and I jerk off Donnie so you just
go you put on the glove I jerk off
Donnie or like you go cow style jrh NBR
when I jerk off Donnie when I jerk off
Donnie
like I like cartoon like Disney like
family friendly and [ __ ] uh and you just
I've been uh I've been like jerking off
that choking your dog off choking your
dog off
choking your dog off
I'm the cool dad now
wait wait wait wait wait hold on so
I'm the cool dad now
strange like dude I'm the cool dad
because imagine if you couldn't jerk off
Donnie Donnie Donnie
Donnie Donnie that's [ __ ] that's
Dopey you bro I gotta control where the
[ __ ] goes
jrh MBR
Ani Donnie
Donnie Donnie I'm the cool dad dude
that's [ __ ] that's to help you bro I
jerk off Donnie and I jerk off Donnie
I jerk off Donnie